Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Wir können es doch gerne ausmachen, Bart Konz. Ausmachen wir es nicht.
Ach, jetzt bin ich wieder schuld.
Ach ja. Guten Tag. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat. 25. Starbuck, du müsstest gleich mal nicht in die Bücher kommen damit, würde ich hören. Ihr hört schon an der lustigen Einleitung, dass es heute wieder der letzte Mittwoch im Monat ist. Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir haben zwei Stunden wieder ein Thema. Uns für euch. Und ich nicht, das Krisi-Radio-Konzert ging ein bisschen länger. Den Jungs soll der Spaß doch gegönnt sein. Willst du jetzt gleich schon meckern oder wollen wir erst mal?
Nein, nein, wir haben hier ganz musisch darüber.
Genau, also Sendung 143 für die Statistiker und die haben wir betitelt Belauscht, Bespitzelt, Abgeschnorchelt, Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer, Grundaussage für alle, die die arbeiten oder sich beworben haben oder die an der Uni sind und da irgendwie unterwegs sind. Die haben in irgendeiner Form damit zu tun, dass sie möglicherweise beobachtet werden. Also der Chef liest eure Mails mit und checkt euer Surfverhalten und sagt euch, wo ihr wart. Kameras gucken zu, wenn ihr aufs Klo geht, hoffentlich nur bis zur Tür. Und die Personalabteilung prüft eure persönlichen Daten mal mit der Kundendatei ab, um zu gucken, ob ihr nicht vielleicht Geschäfte macht mit den Geschäftspartnern. Stichwort Deutsche Bahn. Darüber wollen wir heute reden, wie ihr während der Arbeit abgeschnüffelt werdet, was ihr vor allen Dingen dagegen machen könnt und was unsere Gesetze-Macher als erlaubt und als verboten hinstellen. Mitmachen, mitdiskutieren, Einwurfwürfe einwerfen geht unter 0331 70 97 110. Ruft uns an und erzählt uns von eurer Arbeit, von euren Bewerbungen, von euren Erlebnissen in der Uni. Aber bevor wir einstellen, gibt es noch einen Haufen Wortmeldung und Updates zu vermelden, denn es gab ja kein Trackpack am letzten Wochenende. Deswegen jetzt der Newsticker, der schnell durchlaufen kann.
Ja, sozusagen. Wir haben ja immer ein hohes Mitteilungsbedürfnis beim Chaos Computer Club. Wir haben mehrere Sachen, die wir gerne erzählen wollen. Und zwar, wir planen eine Veranstaltung, eine neue Veranstaltung, eine neue Veranstaltungsreihe. Vielleicht sogar, die sind ja erstmalig die SIGINT. Das ist was? Die SIGINT soll die erste Mal eine Veranstaltung werden zu Themen, die den Chaos Computer Club interessieren, aber nicht so stark international ausgerichtet wie der Kongress, sondern eben schon...
Bisschen übersichtlicher.
Die Themen, die nicht mehr Platz gefunden haben, weil es ein Vortragsprogramm ist. Und vor allem nicht ganz so technisch. Wir wollen es da nicht so sehr an unsere Gemeinde richten, sondern mehr an die Normalen, da ist ein Hund im Studio. Paul ist noch ganz jung, muss lieb zu ihm sein. An die normalen Leute, also die Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmer.
Genau, aber auch ein bisschen an Schüler und Studenten, denn die findet in Köln statt. Und wir wollen uns da auch ein bisschen an ein jüngeres Publikum richten. Deshalb sind viel mehr Vorträge als beim Kongress auf Deutsch. Und Deutsch wird auch die Sprache des Meetings sein. Ja, und wer da mal klicken will, da gibt es auch schon natürlich eine Internetseite, wo man sich informieren kann. Und derzeit ist auch schon der Call raus. Also da heißt es, wir formen auch Leute auf, wenn sie da coole Ideen haben, da Vorträge oder Workshops einzureichen.
Und wenn ich mich ins Internet bewege, finde ich das wo?
Achso, also die Veranstaltung heißt SICKINT. Oh, du hast zufällig die URL im Kopf. Ich würde ja auf SICKINTCCCDE tippen, aber ich würde mal Google benutzen.
Also auf jeden Fall, EventsCCCDE.
EventsCCCDE SICKINT slash 2009. Genau.
Und sie findet statt am 22.
bis 24. Okay, also ansonsten wir fragen, wenn der Link euch zu schnell ging, CCCDE klicken und dann werdet ihr schon fündig werden. SICKINT Ende Mai.
Also wer eine Interesse hat, da laden wir halt herzlich zu ein. Eine andere Sache, die wir gerne noch erwähnen würden, ist die Sache mit den viel besprochenen Internetsperren, die uns in den letzten drei, vier Wochen jetzt schon beschäftigt haben.
Vorum sich ja auch der letzte Chaos Radio, der Chaos Radio Sendung drehte.
Genau, und da haben wir nochmal ein bisschen nachgelegt, weil in so einem braunen Umschlag ist dem Chaos Computer Club der Entwurf für den Vertrag zwischen dem BKA und den Telekommunikationsprovidern zugespielt worden. Ja, da haben wir ihn auf die Webseite gepackt. Also Tessa, da kann man sich diesen Vertrag mal ansehen. Wir haben natürlich auch den anderen Kommentaren mit auf die Webseite getan. Wir haben natürlich festgestellt, dass es, und so viele Juristenstimmen haben uns überein, eine verfassungswidrige Idee ist. Aber wir werden noch sehen. Zunächst haben sie wohl den Termin, den sie geplant haben. Sie wollten im Februar fertig werden mit den Sperren.
Der ist ja jetzt auf Mitte März geschoben, die nächste Anhörung.
Also was auf jeden Fall erwähnt wird, ist, dass die Vertragsänderung irgendwie AGB-Änderung mit sich führt. Das heißt, man hat dann ein Sonderkündigungsrecht und kann den Providern einmal richtig schön zeigen, was man von diesen Abhörwaren hält. Und wir müssen seinen Provider gleich mal kündigen und zu den wenigen gehen, die das irgendwie nicht unterstützen.
Okay, aber abgesehen davon ist ja dieses Jahr Superwahljahr. Da werden noch die ein oder anderen Themen immer wieder mal besprochen werden.
Genau. Deshalb haben wir nämlich noch ein aktueller Thema, was für den Club gerade wichtig ist. Und heute war ja auch die oder sollte die Schülerdemo sein.
Die große, die ein bisschen gefloppt ist, glaube ich.
Ja, ist ein bisschen gefloppt, aber die Sicherheitsbehörden waren sehr viel anwesend.
Naja, aber zu Recht. Also es gab eine Schülerdemo heute in Berlin. Die Schüler haben aufgerufen, zu demonstrieren gegen die Berliner Schülerdatenbank. Bei der letzten Schülerdemo mussten ja ein paar Spacken irgendwie an der Uhr drehen und in der Humboldt-Uni Scheibe spielen und dazu da randalieren. Das ist natürlich dann sofort bedauert worden. Die Schüler haben sich entschuldigt, auch zu Recht. Und dementsprechend war heute das Polizeiaufgebot umso größer, weil, wer weiß, was da an Honks wieder kommt. Die Resonanz bei den Schülern war dann wohl eher geringer. Wir hatten eine Reporterin heute draußen bei den Ralliefritzen am Nachmittag. Da waren, sie sagt 60, 70. Die Agenturmeldungen sagen etwa 100 Leute. Aber jedenfalls nicht viele. Dadurch, dass die Veranstalter mit fast 1000 Leuten gerechnet haben, war die Resonanz eher gering.
Aber wir hatten unsererseits einen Boykott-Aufruf, vor allen Dingen an die Eltern, gar nicht mehr so an die Schüler gerichtet. Und aus einem kleinen Muster schreiben auf die Webseite gestellt, wo wir die Eltern auffordern, ihre Kinder zu schützen und der Weitergabe dieser Daten zu widersprechen.
Wo kann ich, wenn ich Eltern bin, wo kann ich das kriegen? Aber man klickt auf zzz.de und gleich die obere Meldung. Warte mal, bevor wir weitermachen, ganz kurz, wir haben Tom am Telefon, der zur aktuellen Schülerdatenbank Diskussion was sagen möchte. Philipp, kannst du mir Tom reinstellen, bitte? Tom, wir können dich schon sehen, wir können dich aber noch nicht hören.
Ich vermute mal, dass er heute anwesend war und vielleicht war zur aktuellen...
Das wäre ja spannend zu erfahren.
Wir können aber vielleicht zwischendurch nochmal erwähnen, wer sich für aktuelle Veranstaltungen im Berliner Chaos Computer Club interessiert, der muss ganz bis zum Ende dranbleiben, denn wir haben wieder einen Datengarten, so eine kleine Informationsveranstaltung.
Oder ich spult einfach den Podcast vor, wenn wir euch zu viel labern.
Okay, jetzt gehen wir mal Tom fragen.
Am Telefon ist Tom. Hallo Tom, guten Abend. Hallo. Warst du heute dabei bei der Demo?
Ich war heute dabei, ja.
Erzähl mal, unsere Kollegin, die da war als Reporterin, sagt, es waren so 50, 60 Leute, die Nachrichten sagen, es waren etwa 100, was sagst du?
Ich sag auch so ungefähr 50 und ungefähr 200 Polizisten mit Hundestaffe und allem.
Und wie stellst du dich zur Schülerdatei? Wie ist da so deine Meinung?
Ja, also ich bin dagegen, weil es kann nichts Gutes verheißen.
Und warum bist du dagegen? Hast du spezifische Gründe oder ist das mehr so eine generelle Ablehnung von Datensammlungen?
Na ja, also je mehr Daten man sammelt, desto mehr Begehrlichkeiten entstehen natürlich und das Misscross-Risiko steigt. Und aus dem weiß man nicht, wann und wozu die Daten einfach mal umfunktioniert werden.
Beziehungsweise wer irgendwann dann Interesse daran anmeldet, wenn die schon mal da sind.
Ja genau, also Polizei darf ja auch schon drauf zugreifen.
Also hast du eine Ahnung, warum so wenig Resonanz gefunden hat, diese Demonstration?
Wie war es bei dir an der Schule zum Beispiel? Haben da Leute darüber gesprochen, hinzugehen und die Lehrer haben gesagt, nächstes Unterricht oder wie?
Also von der Zeit wäre es im Prinzip jedem möglich gewesen, dahin zu gehen.
War ja spät Nachmittag.
Es ging ja 16 Uhr los. Es gab zwar einige Leute, die noch so nachgeschrieben haben, und so kamen, aber das war ja die Minderheit. Also erstens war es einfach nicht, war nicht gut publik gemacht. Also mir ist nur zufällig so ein Pfeil in die Hand gefallen. Also ich habe in der Schule ungefähr zwei Pfeile gesehen, das ist einfach mal ein bisschen mager. Ja, und dann weiß ich nicht, ich denke mal, viele wussten davon noch, also wussten damit nichts anzufangen. Hey, was ist das? Es geht mich doch nichts an. Nein, mir habe ich irre aus der Schule.
Okay, also einfach zu wenig Informationen gebracht, sonst wären wir wahrscheinlich nicht hingehören.
Es waren zu wenig Informationen und es herrscht auch nicht so das Interesse.
Verstehe. Na ja gut, aber wenigstens haben wir denn von dir einen Bericht zur Lage, weil wir leider heute ja selber nicht anwesend sind. Wir sind aber auch keine Schüler mehr.
Haben wir das auch noch, aber eigentlich jetzt so ein bisschen zurück, extrem zurückrudering zum Thema.
Nein, eigentlich wollten wir nur sagen, dass wir ein Muster schreiben haben. Wir haben noch eine letzte Sache in unserem Chaos Computer Update. Am nächsten Dienstag geht es zur Sache in Karlsruhe. Also wir haben ja hier am Chaos Radio mehrfach darüber berichtet, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe sein Urteil über die Wahlcomputer sprechen wird. Und wir werden auch mit einer kleinen Delegation wieder anwesend sein.
Wir brauchen noch T-Shirts.
Wir brauchen echt mal T-Shirts. Wir haben sogar schon einen Entwurf für T-Shirts. Oliver hat sich da schon mal ganz tolle... Ja, wir haben... Ja, das kann sich schlecht beschreiben. Also visuelle Shirts mit einem Icon. Anyway, wir erwarten uns natürlich einen Urteil, sodass wir zumindest erstmal die eingesetzten NEDAP-Wahlcomputer, die jetzt erlaubt sind und die auch in Brandenburg eingesetzt werden, dass wir die erstmal los sind. Aber wir sind natürlich vor allen Dingen gespannt, was generell zur Frage der Nachvollziehbarkeit und der Transparenz bei computerisierten Wahlen dort kommen wird. Also jeder sollte sich also Dienstag an die Nachrichtenagenturen klemmen und die...
Was heißt die Nachrichtenagenturen? Fritz hören. Wir rufen euch einfach an, wenn ihr auch was ist.
Wir haben ja auch eine Variante.
Ich greife jetzt hier schon die entscheidende Entscheidung ein, aber ich denke, es kriegen wir hin. Okay, nächsten Dienstag suchen ihr seid da. Prima.
Genau. Also wir werden da auch...
Das wird auf jeden Fall sehr spannend.
Ja, wir sind auch selber sehr gespannt. Es ist ja so, dass wir uns da hinsetzen können und uns das vorleden lassen können, weil die Richter ja dann das Urteil vorlesen.
Also wir waren da schon ein paar Mal da und das ist einfach mal echt... Also wenn man so eine Demokratie, wo man mal live miterleben will, ist das Bundesverhassungsgericht. Kann übrigens jeder machen, sich einfach anmelden, Ausweis abgeben, irgendwie um halb 10, viertel 10 ungefähr an der Tür stehen. Und das ist auf jeden Fall sehr lohnenswert. Also irgendwie so mal nach alt vorfahren.
Auch für Nichtjuristen selbst. Hacker sind da sehr entertained.
Na, wir sind gespannt auf euren Bericht. Ein letztes Stichwort, was wir noch haben, bevor wir zum Thema kommen. Wir hatten ja, glaube ich, vor acht Wochen die Sendung zum Thema BitTorrent. Und da gab es diese Woche auch eine neue Entwicklung in Sachen Pirate Bay.
Also die Verhandlung läuft ja gerade jetzt, glaube ich, der siebte oder achte Tag. Und heute, also es lief allgemein relativ günstig. Schon am zweiten, dritten Tag haben sie festgestellt, dass sie den Pirate Bay Betreibern halt gar nicht nachweisen können, dass sie das mit finanziellen Nutzen irgendwie betreiben und irgendwie die Schadenssumme irgendwie extrem zusammengestrichen haben. Ich glaube, von ein paar Millionen auf 500.000 oder so was oder 50.000. Und heute, nee gestern, heute kam irgendwie raus, dass, also sie haben halt irgendwie als Beweis, haben sie halt irgendwie Screenshots vorgelegt von Trackern. Das heißt, Pirate Bay betreibt halt einen eigenen Tracker, worauf halt diese Hashes gehustet werden und darauf bezieht sich halt die ganze Anklage. Und heute kam raus, dass sie zweckerlose Bitorn-Klines verwendet haben. Das heißt irgendwie, es gar keinen Beweis gibt, dass sie tatsächlich die Files von dem Pirate Bay Bitorn-Tacker gezogen haben. Und somit eigentlich irgendwie der Richter hätte heute sagen müssen, die Verhandlung ist irgendwie hiermit beendet und irgendwie geht mal nach Hause.
Hätte heute sagen müssen heißt, ist noch nicht beendet.
Also es wird natürlich irgendwie alles schön juristisch verpackt. Also wir gehen inzwischen davon aus, dass es irgendwie halt so ganz klar jetzt irgendwie das Verfahren da drunter gefahren wird.
Naja, das wird halt nicht die letzte Instanz sein. Ich denke man kann davon ausgehen, dass es sich eh ein paar Jahre zieht, weil wenn halt tatsächlich die Musikindustrie und die Filmindustrie da unterliegen, dann werden sie natürlich eine Vision einlegen oder Berufung. Der Punkt ist, dass dankenswerterweise die Schweden in mehreren Blogs darüber relativ zeitnah in Englisch berichten. Das heißt, man kann, auch wenn man kein Schwedisch kann, oder überhaupt in skandinavischen Sprachen, trotzdem mitlesen. Das finde ich natürlich toll und es gibt sogar einen coolen Twitter.
Also es gibt sogar einen Stream, also Livestream, der es tatsächlich geschafft hat, wirklich aus dem Gerichtssaal irgendwie halt das Audio zumindest rauszustremen, zwar in Schwedisch, aber irgendwie ist da schon wirklich das Hauptnachrichtenthema seit anderthalb Wochen.
Also wer Lust hat, der kann einfach mal ein bisschen googeln und wird ganz sicher dazu eine Menge finden. Das ist spannend.
Oder die andere Suchmaschine eures geringsten Misstrauens verwenden, selbstverständlich. Okay, also wir halten fest für alle aktuellen Entwicklungen in Sachen Wahlcomputer, in Sachen Schülerdatenbank und in Sachen Internetsperre, z.B. zz.com, oder einfach Chaosradio hören oder einen Podcast ziehen oder was auch immer. Wir hören jetzt ganz kurz ein paar Beats, um eine akustische Trennung zu machen und dann geht es los mit dem eigentlichen Thema von der heutigen Sendung Chaosradio 143 Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Auch hierzu gibt es natürlich eine Playliste und eine Trackliste auf pritz.de. Wir gucken, was für Tracks sind, die heute laufen. Outmode waren das mit Reckoning. Damit aber zurück zum eigentlichen Thema, wir wollen ja nicht nur Musik reden, sondern heute geht es um Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Die Sendung trägt einen wunderbaren Titel, Belauscht, Bespitzelt, Abgeschnorchelt. Welche Möglichkeiten hat eigentlich euer Arbeitgeber, euch auszuhorchen, euch abzuschnüffeln und zu gucken, was ihr da so eigentlich treibt und welche Möglichkeiten habt ihr, euch dagegen zu wehren? Deine erste Anrufer unter 0331 70 97 110 ist Klaus. Guten Abend Klaus.
Schönen guten Abend. Grüße dich.
Wo arbeitest du?
Ich bin bei der Deutschen Bahn AG.
Du bist bei der Bahn. Kannst du sagen, was du da machst oder gibt es da Ärger?
Ich bin Lokführer.
Lokführer, okay.
Was mich irritiert hat, vor zwei Jahren haben wir alle ein Dienst-Handy bekommen.
Das hört sich jetzt mal gut an, für dienstliche Belange, super Sache. Da ist eine Doppel-7-Karte drin, das heißt, wir haben gleichzeitig eine private Telefonnummer, die ist einfach nur eine Ziffer weiter. Von der Telekom, Rahmenvertrag, bisschen subventioniert, also günstiger.
Und mit dem darfst du dann privat telefonieren?
Mit dem darf ich dann privat telefonieren. Eine kleine Umschaltung, dienstlich, dann privat. Die Frage ist, wer bekommt den Einzelgesprächsnachweis noch außer mir? Vielleicht die Deutschland AG?
Das heißt, deine Privatgespräche bezahlst du auch selbst und du erhältst dafür deinen Einzelverbindungsnachweis?
Na, es gibt ja zwei separate Nummern, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Das heißt, es gibt auf jeden Fall dann auch zwei Einzelverbindungsnachweise. Also die gibt es ja immer pro Nummer. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass nicht eventuell dein Arbeitgeber irgendwie auch daran kommt, weil er weiß ja irgendwie deine Telefonnummer, aber es sollte auf jeden Fall nicht passieren.
Ja, das wäre sicherlich ohne dein Wissen nicht legal. Warst du denn auch ein Betroffener bei den Schlüffelaktionen Eichhörnchen und Babylon, also über diese Skandale, über die ja alle geredet haben?
Ja, wenn ich bedenke, dass alle abgehört wurden und ich schon seit 20 Jahren dabei bin, klar.
Und wenn du jetzt immer so hörst, jetzt wird dir mal gesagt, naja, ist ja nichts passiert, war ja nur ein Datenabgleich und wie fühlt sich das so an?
Fühlt sich gar nicht gut an.
Wenn man Informationen an den Eigentümern, also an das Volk, an Politiker, zum Beispiel von der FDP, sind ja einige sehr interessiert, was bei uns so abgeht. Missstände gibt es an jeder Firma. Aber dann wäre doch interessant, wenn dann abgeglichen würde, wer telefoniert mit welchem Abgeordneten. Ja, das wäre dann dieser einzige Sprichstum, da wäre dann doch hochinteressant, welcher Mitarbeiter. Denn ich glaube kaum, dass Mitarbeiter von ihrem dienstlichen Telefonanruf oder dienstliche E-Mail-Kontakte mit solchen Leuten aufnehmen. Also so blöd kann man eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Habt ihr als Bahnmitarbeiter eigentlich intern einen Brief bekommen von der Geschäftsleitung, die gesagt haben, okay, situationsfolgendermaßen, wir entschuldigen euch und uns?
Ja, wird nicht hingenommen und nicht verfolgt.
Ist es denn auch das Problem, dass du siehst, dass das Unrechtsbewusstsein da einfach gar nicht da ist und jetzt ein bisschen abgetan wird, als, naja, Entschuldigung, ein bisschen Datenabgleich, jetzt habt ihr euch mal nicht so?
Ja, genau.
Vor einigen Jahren bekriegt man auch einen Dienstausweis, hat jeder Mitarbeiter.
Und dann ist aufgefallen, persönlich, dass da ein RFID-Ship drin ist.
Das haben sie euch vorher auch nicht gesagt, oder?
Nö, das war vorher nicht so nötig, man sah nur von außen und schiebte sie, diese Geldkartenfunktion war drauf, aber dass da ein RFID-Ship drin ist, das musste man uns ja nicht sagen.
Habt ihr ja mal gespeichert?
Was da gespeichert wird, weiß ich nicht, aber was eher für Kantinen und Zugangsberechtigung ist, das ist wahrscheinlich mal fair.
Also ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie auch schon ein ziemlicher Eingriff, was ich meine, hast du mal gefragt, bzw. über ein Betriebsrat oder so, mal irgendwie nachfragen lassen, warum sie es da reingemacht haben und zu welchen Zwecken?
Zu welchen Zwecken? Ich habe versucht, den Datenschutzbeauftragten bei DB Cargo zu kriegen, bei der Bahn AG, da schwer herauszukriegen. Eine zwei Jahre alte Telefonnummer war aber noch aktuell im Internet. Und ja, wäre ja nicht so schlimm, und da wäre ja nur eine Mitarbeiternummer drauf. Nur welche Daten, die ja mit verbinden, zum Beispiel in der Kantine, wo in der Kantine, wann in der Kantine, was gegessen, wäre ja auch interessant.
Prinzipiell ist das Problem, wenn sie euch nicht darüber informieren, ist das schon ein ziemlicher Eingriff in eure Persönlichkeitsrechte. Das Gleiche hat man bei diesen Payback-Karten auch gehabt, wo sie gesagt haben, ist sowas nicht drin und dann war es halt doch drin. Und es ist halt schon ein ziemlicher Eingriff und da sollte man eigentlich auch nochmal was dagegen tun.
Ja gut, aber was wollen wir dagegen tun? Das ist unsere ganz offizielle Mitarbeiterausweis. Mittlerweile sage ich auch jedem, dass so ein Chip da drin ist. Mit unserer neuen Taschennappe kann man den schön durchleuchten und man sieht den Chip und die Antenne auch so schön. Und wenn man den ein bisschen einreißt, dass die Antenne kaputt ist, kriegt man leider in der Kantine kein verpflichtetes Essen mehr.
Also was mich mal noch interessieren würde, habt ihr denn unter Kollegen mal über diese Datenabgleiche geredet?
Ja, bei den meisten Kollegen ist da wirklich keinerlei Verständnis. Vielleicht schon, aber kein Unrecht, du wusst schon, ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen nach der Mutter. Das ist wie in einer normalen Gesellschaft auch, die pflanzt sich das durch.
Also die nehmen das einfach wirklich so hin und sagen, das ist ja nicht so schlimm, weil wir haben nichts zu verbergen und...
Ja, ja, genau. Wenn man den Leuten mal erklärt, was man mit dem Internet, mit ihren Daten also machen kann, wo man sie alles so anmelden kann, dann werden sie auf einmal hellhörig. Dass man so G-EZ anmelden und solche Spielereien machen kann mit ihrem Namen, mit ihrem Bild, wo man sie alle mit welchen Profilen oder Spurensätzen von Gruppen der CSU anmelden kann und so etwas, dann werden sie hellhörig.
Also um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen mit der Doppelsim im Handy, glaube die einfachste Lösung ist, ein eigenes Mobiltelefon zu benutzen.
Ja, natürlich habe ich auch. Ich habe diese Privatnutzung gar nicht gemacht und habe dann eine anonyme Simkarte.
Das geht schon von dieser Prämisse aus, dass dein Arbeitgeber sich ohnehin über die Rechtslage hin wechselt, als ob er gezeigt hätte, dass er das auch tut und dass er das in Zukunft auch tut. Ich denke mal, da ist der Punkt, wo wir deshalb fordern müssen, dass es klare gesetzliche Regeln gibt, die man auch versteht. Und genau darüber wollen wir heute reden. Also die Situation, dass man sich damit abfindet, dass die vielleicht hinter meinem Rücken dieses und jenes tun, weil sie sich ja auch über andere Gesetze schon weggesetzt haben, das wollen wir halt genau nicht mehr.
Und das ist halt auch die politische Forderung.
Naja, aber da ist halt genau der Datenschutzbeauftragte bzw. der Betriebsrat genau dafür zuständig. Und deswegen, wie meine ich irgendwie, sag mal dem Betriebsrat Bescheid, und wie die sollen das mal rausfinden. Also auch für die FAD-Karte, weil es halt genau das Gleiche wie alle anderen Datenabgleiche oder diese Doppelsim. Das sind halt Sachen, die halt einfach mal geklärt werden müssen, bzw. wo auch der Betriebsrat dann sagen kann, wir haben was dagegen.
Na, fangen wir doch mal ganz direkt. Wusstest du denn, an wen du dich bei deinem Arbeitgeber wendest?
Ja, Betriebsrat, na klar, das ist bekannt.
Aber ihr habt auch einen betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten?
Ja, dessen Nummer habe ich auch nach langen Suchen rausbekommen.
Nur ich glaube nicht, dass der vielleicht der Richtige ist, weil wissen, droht dich erst, wenn es ein Lied ist.
Das heißt, du würdest ihm vielleicht gar nicht vertrauen. Hättest du noch eine andere Idee, wo du dich dann hinwenden könntest?
Ja, Datenschutzbeauftragte des Landes oder des NRW hier bei uns.
Genau, das könntest du natürlich auch machen. Und das ist eben auch so eine Sache, das ist genau so eine Forderung. Man muss die so betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten natürlich mit besseren Rechten ausstatten. Damit nämlich auch die Mitarbeiter und die ganze Belegschaft sich vertrauensvoll hinwenden können. Die brauchen genauso ein Kündigungsschutzrecht, wie etwa bei Betriebsräten üblich ist. Und das muss genau auch in die Gesetze.
Das sagt ja schon mal echt viel über die Situation geradeaus. Wenn du dich als Mitarbeiter nicht mehr traust, den dafür zuständigen anderen Mitarbeiter anzusprechen auf das Problem, dann ist halt einfach mal ganz deutlich was schief gelaufen.
Wie die aktuelle Rechtslage im Moment in Deutschland ist, es gibt ja immer mal wieder Bestrebungen, da ein Gesetz durchzudrücken, und dann verläuft das immer mal wieder im Sande. Würde ich vorschlagen, klären wir nach den Nachrichten, weil wir marschieren straff auf die halb elf zu. Und dann werden wir uns weiter mit der Thematik beschäftigen.
Klaus dir auch.
Danke schön. Tschüss. Wenn ihr euch auch beteiligen wollt an der Diskussion zum Thema Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer, wie ist es bei euch im Betrieb, in der Firma, im Büro, in der Uni oder aber bei irgendeiner Bewerbung, musstet ihr da komische Sachen machen, dann ruft einfach an 0331 70 97 110.
Langsberg, 11. Juli, der kommt schneller als man denkt. In der Berliner Wohlheide.
Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt und mehr Infos. Fritzee.
Das Fahrrad-Urlaub-Racing-Gehäuse.
Live in Berlin und präsentiert von Fritz.
Mit Philipp Berger. In Berlin sind neue schwere Fälle von Kindesmisshandlungen bekannt geworden. Seit gestern Abend musste die Polizei neuen, verwahrlosen und geschlagenen Kindern vor ihren Eltern retten und sie dem Kindernotdienst übergeben. Die Kinder waren zwischen 2 und 13 Jahre alt. Die Sprecherin des Kindernotdienstes Köhn sagte der deutschen Presseagentur, alle ihre Berliner Einrichtungen seien voll. Bei einem Flugzeugabsturz auf dem Amsterdamer Flughafen sind neun Menschen getötet worden. Rund 80 Passagiere wurden verletzt, davon 25 schwer. Die in Istanbul gestartete Maschine befand sich im Lander an Flug, als sie auf einem Acker aufschlug und in drei Teile zerbrach. Die Unlücksursache gibt Rätsel auf, da kein Feuer ausbrach. Deshalb wird darüber spekuliert, ob dem Flugzeug das Kerosin ausgegangen sein könnte. In Berlin haben Jugendliche gegen die Schülerdatei protestiert. Allerdings fiel die Demo deutlich kleiner aus als geplant. Die Initiative Bildungsblockaden einreißen, hatte auf bis zu 1000 Teilnehmer gehofft, es kamen weniger als 100. Die Schülerdatei kommt Mitte März. In ihr werden 16 Daten von jedem Berliner Schüler gespeichert, wie zum Beispiel Anschrift und Muttersprache. Mehrfache Volksverhetzungen hat dem Rechtsextremisten Horst Mahler Gefängnis eingebracht. Laut Anklage hatte er unter anderem den Holocaust als die gewaltigste Lüge der Weltgeschichte bezeichnet. Das Landgericht München hat den 70-Jährigen zu einer Haftstrafe von 6 Jahren verurteilt. Der Vorsitzende Richter sagte zum Schluss, Mahler sei gänzlich unbelehrbar. In der Fußball-Champions League ist Achtelfinale. Als einzige deutsche Mannschaft ist Bayern München noch dabei und sie bleiben auch dabei. Kurz vor Abpfiff steht es 4-0 für Bayern München. Sie haben auswärts bei Sporting Lissabon gespielt. Und die Berliner Eisbären stehen in der deutschen Eishockey-Liga vor dem Gewinn der Vorrunde. Die Berliner Eisbären siegten im Nachholspiel gegen Adler Mannheim 7-2 und führen jetzt in der Tabelle mit 4 Punkten vor den Hannover Skorpions. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neurupin, Angermünde, Cottbus-Wittenberge und auch Frankfurt melden 4 Grad, Potsdam und Berlin 5 Grad. Heute Nacht sind dichte Wolken am Himmel. Ab Mitternacht kann es zunächst über Havel landen, später überall in Berlin und Brandenburg kräftig regnen. Am Donnerstag bekommen wir neben einigen Schauern noch etwas Sonne bei 7 Grad und es wird windig. Verkehr, keine Störung, gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder?
Herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio auf Fritz Nr. 143. Belauscht, Bespitzelt, Abgeschnorchelt, Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Das ist das Thema heute. Ihr seid eingeladen mit anzurufen und über eure Erfahrungen bei euch auf Arbeit oder bei einer Uni zu reden unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir gucken gleich mal auf die aktuelle Gesetzeslage. Was darf eigentlich der Arbeitgeber? Was darf er nicht? Es fiel gerade schon das interessante Stichwort, dass der Datenschutzbeauftragte im Betrieb gar nicht vom Kündigungsschutz profitieren kann. Das heißt, er kann euch zwar die Beichte abnehmen oder eure Fragen kriegen, aber ist ja unbequem. Dann kann es auch ihm an den Kragen gehen. Wir fragen mal Chris. Hallo Chris, guten Abend. Wo arbeitest du denn eigentlich, sag mal? Du arbeitest bei Kaisers beim Sicherheitsdienst? Alles klar, okay. Das sind die Jungs, die abends dann da stehen und gucken, dass da irgendwie kein Unsinn passiert in den Läden.
Und aber das finde ich trotzdem schon schlimm. Alleine, wenn man telefonieren will, Karte rein, da hast du schon, weißt du schon, ein ganzer noch mehr was dran getan hat. Kameras, Open Ends, ich finde, dass das System ziemlich gefickt ist, also dass das Menschenrecht ziemlich missbraucht wird.
Aber Moment, wir müssen nochmal, das ist jetzt ein bisschen der zweite Schritt vor dem ersten. Du sagst, wenn du arbeitest und telefonieren willst, kann man anhand deiner Karte...
Karte und da sind alle meine Daten drauf.
Auf der Telefonkarte? Also du meinst auf deinem Dienst Handy?
Nein, wenn ich von...
Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht.
Ich habe es auch noch nicht.
Also du meinst, wenn ich von Festnetz, von Chaos telefoniere, muss ich eine Karte reinführen, sonst kann ich nicht telefonieren. Da ist alles drauf, das wird nicht aufgeteichelt, keine Ahnung, aber ich werde ziemlich bespitzelt, also ich finde, weil ich nicht private Affäre habe, alle anderen wissen, was getan wurde.
Ich glaube, ich verstehe, du meinst, du hast eine Zugangskarte für das Festnetz-Telefon bei Kaisers.
Genau, das war schon mal in der Presse, wegen Einkaufsmärkte und es war zwar etwas mit Toiletten gehabt, aber trotzdem, es haut volle Kanäle hin.
Na gut, die Discounter sind natürlich sehr stark in der Presse gewesen wegen der folgenden Videokameras, aber auch wegen der Observation teilweise. Die haben ja richtige Akten erstellt.
Aber das erinnert mich so an Mauerzeit, also vor der Mauerzeit. Da hat man auch gerne kontrolliert und immer schön alles gewusst.
Da hast du fühlt sich zurückgeworfen irgendwie.
Ja genau, also es entwickelt sich mehr, also es ist keine Mauer da, aber es ist genau wie früher. Obwohl es nicht meine Zeit ist, also ich bin 26, aber trotzdem. Ich meine, von Hören und Reden, ja.
Okay, aber nochmal zurück zu dieser Zugangskarte für das Telefon, mit der du dich unwohl fühlst. Auf der steht wahrscheinlich drauf, wie du heißt.
Ja alles, alles, was ich bin.
Ja, okay.
Das ist aber ein allgemeines Problem heutzutage. Also nicht nur in Einkaufsbärken, sondern halt allgemein in Großstädten.
Kameras gibt es überall.
Genau, es sind dann einfach viel zu billig geworden. Und irgendwie diesen Kampf gegen Kameras zu führen, ist leider irgendwie relativ aussichtlos.
Ich meine, ich finde gut, dass man kontrolliert. Ich hatte jetzt vor einer Kurzpreisende Sendung bei Fritz, da ging es darum, mehr Internetshots, also sprich für Kinder. Ich bin Vater. Ich bin zwei- dreifacher Vater. Und das finde ich gut, weil man dann halt mehr darauf achtet, dass die Kinder wo reingehen, weil Pädophile halt das ausnutzen. Also ich nenne sie jetzt Pädophile, weil es sind Pädophile, die auf kleine Kinder stehen und sie misshandeln. Dafür habe ich völliges Verständnis.
Aber das hat ja jetzt in dem Moment relativ wenig zu tun mit dem Thema Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitgeber.
Vielleicht sollten wir in dem Zusammenhang einfach mal darüber sprechen, wollen wir jetzt die Videoüberwachung etwas schon haben, wie ist denn da eigentlich gerade die Rechtslage? Ich meine, das gibt ja durchaus dazu Entscheidungen. Ja, und bei der Videoüberwachung gibt es sehr klare Entscheidungen. Der Punkt ist, verdachtsunabhängig ist die unzulässig.
Das heißt, einfach nur draufgucken und vielleicht passiert irgendwas?
Genau, das ist eine Entscheidung vom Bundesarbeitsgericht, und zwar schon aus dem Jahr 2004. Das heißt, da ist das über die Gerichtsentscheidungen. Wir haben also kein Gesetz, wo das drin steht, sondern eben über Gerichte entschieden.
Warte mal, Chris, um jetzt mal beim Thema von Chris zu bleiben, der in einem Supermarkt arbeitet in der Sicherheitsabteilung. Da gibt es ja auch überall Kameras, um Ladendiefschäle und so weiter zu beobachten.
Wie weit das mit der Kontrolle gehen?
Man muss unterscheiden zwischen den Kameras, die Mitarbeiter filmen und die Kunden filmen. Und die Verdachtsunabhängige Videoüberwachung von Mitarbeitern ist so erstmal unzulässig. Man darf also nicht pro forma da irgendwie erstmal jeden filmen. Das betrifft die Mitarbeiter, genau. Wenn man einen konkreten Verdacht hat, etwa wenn sich bei Inventuren herausstellt, da sind jetzt Fehlbeträge, dann ist es was anderes. Dann kann man das machen, aber auch nur als sogenannte Ultima Ratio. Das heißt, andere Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die eben weniger schweren Eingriff sind, nicht gehen oder nicht praktisch sind. Und das ist eben auch schon seit vielen Jahren so. Wie gesagt, das Urteil ist von 2004. Da war auch so ein Beispiel, da war so eine Kassiererin und da war die Inventur falsch und dann haben sie beschlossen, ja das geht. Aber das Mitbestimmungsrecht muss natürlich trotzdem gegeben sein. Das heißt, der Betriebsrat etwa darf da mitreden. Oder der Datenschutzbeauftragte, der ihn hat.
Aber Betriebsrat müsste auch gerne mal unter der Decke mit.
Na klar, dass nicht alle Betriebsräte so unabhängig sind, wie man sich wünscht, sind andere Probleme. Das ist sicherlich sehr unterschiedlich in Betrieben. Also ich kenne auch sehr unabhängige Betriebsräte.
Also um das jetzt mal noch zusammenzufassen mit der Verdachtsunabhängigen und dem Verdachtsmoment. Wenn der Geschäftsführer, die Geschäftsleitung den berechtigten Verdacht hat, dass Mitarbeiter irgendwie sich gegen die Firma wenden, also klauen oder, ich mutige, Dinge kaputt machen oder so, dann ist das auf einer rechtlichen Grundlage. Muss man dann informiert werden als Mitarbeiter?
Ja genau, die allgemeinen Mitbestimmungsregeln gelten natürlich trotzdem. Es ist halt der Betriebsrat oder der Datenschutzbeauftragte.
Jukris, wir halten glaube ich erstmal fest, dass die Thematik im Supermarkt, im Sicherheitsdienst ähnlich pikant ist wie zum Beispiel bei der Bahn oder so.
Genau, die lassen auf einer Art tun, sie die Persönlichkeit mehr angreifen als die, also sie sind mehr gegen die Bestimmung als es sein sollte.
Und im Zweifelsfall einfach, also wenn du mit deinem Betriebsrat da nicht reden kannst oder es keinen gibt, dann einfach zum nächsten höheren Stelle gehen. Da gibt es ja immer noch eine Option. Datenschutzbeauftragte. Datenschutzbeauftragte, also alles klar.
Wir wünschen euch noch viel Spaß und hört sich.
Dir auch, Chris. Chaosradio auf Fritz, 0331 77 97 110. Wir haben gerade die rechtlichen Schritte angeschnitten. Das war ein ganz interessanter Einwurf von Chris zum Thema, wenn der Chef ein Verdacht hat, dass irgendwas passiert. Der Chef hat ja unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen die Möglichkeit und das Recht, seine Mitarbeiter zu kontrollieren, überwachen, zu beschnüffeln, nennt es wie er wollt. Also Beispiel Einzelhandelsgeschäft. Wenn der Chef das Gefühl hat oder den berechtigten Verdacht hat, es wird geklaut, dann gibt es sicherlich Möglichkeiten, das zu überprüfen. Aber der Verdacht muss da sein. Wie kriegt der den Verdacht aber mit?
Da hat man natürlich keine allgemeine Regel. Da muss man schon den Einzelfall betrachten. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen das generelle Problem. Wir haben eben kein Gesetz, wo das drin steht, wo man klare Regelungen hätte, die natürlich für den Einzelfall immer noch nicht ausdifferenziert sind. Aber zumindest erstmal, wo jeder reingucken kann und sagen kann, ok, Videoüberwachung, Internetüberwachung oder sonst irgendwie ist da und da geregelt. Sondern wir haben halt eine Fülle, sind über zehn Gesetze, die die Arbeitgeber da kennen müssen. Das ist halt ein sehr unübersichtliches Gebiet. Deswegen wird ja auch schon seit jetzt mehr als zehn Jahren gefordert, dass man ein eigenes Arbeitnehmerdatenschutzgesetz findet. Denn die Skandale, die wir jetzt haben, also bei Lidl, bei Rewe, bei Burger King oder bei Hagebau, da waren ja wirklich viele Beispiele oder eben bei der Bahn, die sind eigentlich auch gerade dieser Unübersichtlichkeit, die er scheudet und dass die Unternehmen jetzt in den Medien irgendwie kommen und sagen, naja, das ist ja alles eine juristische Grauzone und eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Also keiner weiß es so genau und das machen wir erstmal.
Und es sind sehr, es ist eigentlich relativ viel, wenn man sich mal anguckt, was das alles betrifft. Wir haben jetzt ja so gehabt Videoüberwachung, aber es betrifft natürlich auch Internetüberwachung, also Surfverhalten, E-Mails, Chats, also wenn man Computer auf Arbeit benutzen kann. Natürlich Mobiltelefonet hatten wir schon, aber auch GPS-Überwachung. Natürlich so eine Frage wie sogenannte freiwillige Drogen- und Gentests, überhaupt medizinische Daten, Personalakten, Personaldatenverarbeitung im Ausland oder innerhalb von Konzernen. Dann so eine fremdbestimmten Selbstauskünfte. Also wenn man dem Arbeitgeber etwa erlaubt, dass er von Sicherheitsbehörden über eine Selbstauskünfte einholt. Haben wir zum Beispiel bei der WM ganz viel gesehen. Dann natürlich auch Daten von Bewerbern. Dann kommt er noch einmal dazu. Dann überhaupt, was passiert mit den ärztlichen Daten, etwa von Betriebsärzten. Wer darf darauf zugreifen? All diese Fragen. Und natürlich Telefonüberwachung. Die Firmen haben ja oft eigene betriebsinterne Netze. Was ist damit? Nach dem Pedecov-Skandal reden natürlich jetzt wieder viele drüber. Aber für iDESIT brauchen wir halt irgendwie eine einheitliche Regelung.
Ich bin jetzt verwundert, da gibt es keine.
Ich habe mal nachgezählt. Ich habe tatsächlich 11 eigene Gesetze gefunden, die man kennen muss. Die großen sind bekannt, das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und die Landesdatenschutzgesetze. Aber es sind auch so etwas wie Telemediengesetz, dann die Telekommunikationsdatenschutzverordnung, die Betriebsverfassungsgesetze, Betriebsvereinbarung, dann natürlich die Arbeitsverträge, das Gleichbehandlungsgesetz, weil es ja auch manchmal Diskriminierungsfragen betrifft, oder auch die EU-Richtlinien. Das nimmt kein Ende. Und da hat natürlich auch selbst der betriebliche Datenschutzbeauftragte, der ja zumindest noch ein bisschen spezialistisch ist, oft den Überblick verloren.
Beziehungsweise selbst der Chef, den Überblick verloren, weil der sagt, ich muss gucken, dass der Laden läuft.
Und der muss auch die aktuelle Gesetzgebung kennen, weil natürlich etwa die Urteile zur Internetüberwachung oder zur Videoüberwachung, die muss man halt kennen. Und da ist einfach ein Regelungsbedarf, und dass sich jetzt irgendwie der Innenminister hinschaltet und sagt, na also diese Legislaturperiode schaffen wir jetzt ja nicht mehr, obwohl uns das jetzt seit geschlagenen zehn Jahren versprochen wird, das ist einfach ein Zustand, wo man sich fragen muss, wir hatten da eigentlich die Datenskandale verschuldet.
Es gab viele wichtige Gesetze, die noch schnell durchgepeitscht werden müssen, um halt noch mehr Daten zu sammeln gerade.
Du hast gerade verschiedene Firmen angesprochen, wo so eine Fälle aufgetaucht sind. Wir haben gerade gehört von Al-Bahn, das ist natürlich das aktuellste und bekannteste. Die Geschichte, die auch sehr weit rumgegangen war, die Geschichte bei Lidl, dass da Verkäuferinnen per Kamera überwacht wurden, wurde dokumentiert, wie oft die aufs Klo gehen und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es da noch mehr so eine Beispiele?
Ja, es sind wie gesagt eine ganze Reihe von den Discountern.
Dann lasst du mal so zwei, drei rausnehmen.
Oder Einzelhandelsketten, sind fast alle betroffen. Also durchaus auch nicht nur die Discounter, also die Billigketten, sondern eben auch Rewe war dabei. Oder wir hatten halt diesen Baumarkt noch, Hagebau oder auch Burger King, das ging durch die Presse und man muss sehen, dass man da immer nur die dicken Dinger liest. Das ist halt mittlerweile so eine Art Generalverdacht. Das heißt, die Mitarbeiter irgendwie auszuspähen oder zu Video bewachen, ist so ein Kavaliersdedikt geworden.
Gegenargument, Gegenanzeige, habe lange auch im Einzelhandel gearbeitet. Und da ist es natürlich gang und gäbe, dass das Geschäft Video überwacht wird, um Ladendiebstähle zum Beispiel zu verhindern. Und da gibt es 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 10 Sicherheitsleute, die entweder in zivil oder in ganz normalen Uniformen durch den Laden gehen und aber auch natürlich diese Videoüberwachung, diese Monitore sich angucken, um einfach Ladendiebstähle zu verhindern. Ist das jetzt schon feil an der Arbeitnehmerausschnüffelung? Eigentlich ja nicht.
Also hat Konstanz hier vorhin schon gesagt, dass du wirklich unterscheiden wirst, ob es in den Geschäftsräumen oder in den Räumen für die Mitarbeiter ist. Und halt Geschäftsräume, da sind die Kameras ja wirklich installiert, um Ladendiebe, nicht anders los, sondern schon anders bezogen gegen Diebstahl.
Und sie sind ja gerade nicht heimlich, denn in der Regel sollen die ja auch abschrecken, einfach Ladendiebe und man hat eine Verpflichtung, ein Schild dran zu machen und zu sagen, hier wird Video überwacht. Da muss man natürlich unterscheiden.
Weil ich das gerade auch den Einwand so verstanden habe, dass der Kollege bei Kaisers arbeitet in irgendeinem Supermarkt und da hängen natürlich überall Kameras. Klar, bleibt es nicht aus, dass auch du dann mal durchs Bild läufst. Schwierige zwiespältige Geschichte. Also wir halten fest, eine richtige gesetzliche Regelung gibt es noch nicht. Der Wust angesetzt wird immer größer, weil es sich immer wieder verändert. Da brauchen wir halt mal eins. Und wir kriegen keins mehr.
Es gibt sehr viele Vorschläge auf dem Tisch, weil ja seit Jahren die Gewerkschaften, aber auch die Datenschutzbeauftragten daran arbeiten. Und wir haben auch eine EU-Richtlinie, die das ja nun fordert. Die bräuchten es einfach nur mal beschließen. Und schon die rot-grüne Regierung hat uns das im Koalitionsvertrag versprochen.
Okay, aber jetzt spekulative Frage, warum drücken die sich denn davor offensichtlich?
Ich denke, dass das erst in 2008 wirklich Priorität bekommen hat. Also Datenschutz wird jetzt erst wieder sexy. Und die Skandale sind natürlich immer so ein Auslöser, um politisch endlich mal ein Handeln fordern zu können. Sonst, die haben einfach geschneicht im Bundesinnenministerium, dass nichts passiert.
Das ist doch ein super Wahlkampfthema.
Eigentlich schon. Also was ich gerade für die FDP, also für die Leute, die sich als Datenschutz auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, das ist eigentlich genau das Thema, womit man jetzt schön in den Wahlkampf ziehen kann.
Genau, ich meine, wir haben immerhin 30 Millionen Erwerbstätige. Und das sind doch Fehler.
Einer davon ist Nico, der ist bei uns am Telefon. Hallo Nico, guten Abend. Grüße dich. Wann arbeitest du?
Ich bin Berufskraftfahrer.
Und ich sage mal so, der Berufskraftfahrer, der ist schon der glesernde Mensch seit den 70er Jahren.
Das heißt, du hast deine Obu im Cockpit?
Für alle nicht Kraftfahrer, was macht eine Onboard Unit?
Mein Chef zahlt pro gefahrenden Kilometer bei 1, 15 Euro 15 Cent und mein Chef kann mir genau sagen, ich bin angenommen um 21.30 Uhr auf der Autobahn aufgefahren in Franksdorf und bin um 23 Uhr, schießt mich tot, wieder runtergefahren in Michendorf.
Und zu der Zeit gab es eigentlich gar keinen Stau? Wieso brauchst du so lange?
Genau. Aber genau dafür war noch die Daten eigentlich nicht gedacht. Die Daten sind ja wirklich nur zur Abrechnung der Lkw-Maut. Also dein Chef sollte nach meinem Wissen an diese Daten eigentlich gar nicht rankommen. Wie kommt er da ran oder irgendwelche Begründung hat er dafür?
Da musst du deine Rechnung kriegen.
Er kriegt ja die Rechnung und da sieht er die gefahrenden Mautstrecken. Und er sieht, wann ich auf der Autobahn aufgefahren bin und wann ich die Autobahn verlassen habe. Und dazu gibt es ja auch noch diesen Tachographen, sprich Tachoscheibe oder digitalen Tachographen, was es jetzt momentan gerade gibt.
Wo nachvollziehbar ist, zu welcher Uhrzeit du mit welcher Geschwindigkeit gefahren bzw. Um Lenkzeiten zu nachprüfen zu können und um zu gucken, ob du zu schnell gefahren bist.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja wirklich mit der Onboard-Unit und dem Autoprechung, das ist mir jetzt ja wirklich eher neu. Soweit ich informiert bin, haben sie wirklich damals bei der Einführung gesagt, die Daten werden halt nur der zur Abrechnungsstelle übermittelt, dass die halt irgendwie sagen können, wie viel Geld derjenige bezahlen muss, dass dein Chef die genauen Daten kriegt und irgendwie sagen kann, wann du auf die Autobahn gefahren bist und wie du runtergefahren bist. Würde ich eigentlich sagen, dass das zumindest nicht in den Verträgen damals drin gestand?
Also ich bin auch nur soweit informiert und ich weiß es daher, weil mein Chef mich schon mal darauf angesprochen hat, was ich in der Zwischenzeit gemacht habe. Also auf Deutsch gesagt kann mir mein Chef sagen, du hast dann und dann da und da gestanden oder geschlafen, obwohl du hättest eigentlich arbeiten müssen.
Und wie fühlt es dich dabei, so dauerhaft über acht geworden zu sein?
Also ich sag mal so, ich find's nicht okay, weil dadurch kommt ja bei uns noch dazu diese GPS-Überwachung. Also wir haben praktisch, also der Kraftfahrer, der gläserne Mensch, ist in meinen Augen.
Ihr seid aber im Prinzip dann eigentlich schon seit Jahrzehnten gewöhnt. Das hat sich jetzt nur noch mal so ein bisschen verfeinert, nicht wahr? Von der Art der Daten.
Also es wird immer schlimmer, mal gucken, was wir sich als nächstes einfallen lassen.
Naja, nun muss man natürlich sehen, bei den Fernfahrern ist es ja lange so gewesen, dass die gesetzlichen Regelungen, was so die Fahrzeiten betrifft, auch immer wieder, wenn sie überprüft wurden, überschritten wurden. Das heißt, es ist ja auch so ein bisschen eine Gegenreaktion, auch für die Verschärfung der Gesetze, deswegen, weil so viele eben die Lenkzeiten nicht eingehalten haben.
Das kann man halt genau an der Tachoscheibe, am Tachomaten feststellen. Also muss man nicht die Totalüberwachung der Fahrer...
Ja, aber Konstanze hat insofern schon recht, dass bei Berufen oder bei Gewerben, die mit Menschenleben im weitesten Sinne zu tun haben, also Transportgewerbe und so weiter und so fort, dass da natürlich im externen Stellen kontrollieren müssen, ob du da deinen Beruf...
Kontrolle ist okay, aber die Frage ist, wie man es kontrolliert. Und es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob man sagt, der ist jetzt acht Stunden gefahren, oder ob man sagen kann, der ist 13.45 auf die Autobahn und irgendwie hat dann da gepennt und ist 15.00 oder 17.00 wieder runtergefahren.
Ich würde eigentlich eher davon aus, dass man da noch, man kann eigentlich noch viel schlechter argumentieren gegen die Überwachung und Kontrolle. Weil ich glaube, die öffentliche Meinung, gerade so bei Fernfahrern ist ja, ach Gott, die machen eher, was sie wollen, die halten ihre Längzeiten nicht ein.
Und außerdem stören sie mich auf der Autobahn.
Also ich kann das sehr gut verstehen, dass man sich da stark überwacht fühlt. Genau. Also wenn man jetzt selber der Fahrer ist und weiß, dass der Chef, und wer weiß nicht noch, sehr genau wissen kann, wann man wo anhält.
Im Zweifel hätte ich deinen Chef einfach feuern können. Deswegen, wenn du jetzt wirklich irgendwo angehalten hast und eigentlich hättest arbeiten müssen, dann wäre das ja schon ein Kündigungsgrund mehr oder weniger. Oder irgendwie halt unwissend, an die Daten zu kommen und dann auf einmal zu sagen, du bist jetzt gefeuert, weil ich habe die Daten hier von der Mautstelle gekriegt. Das fände ich schon ein bisschen eigenartig. Ich würde dir auch raten, nachzufragen, ob das wirklich okay so ist.
Gab es da vom Chef auch eine Info an dich, über die aktuellen Informationen, die er so sammelt, dass er sagt, pass mal auf, Nico, ich weiß anhand der Maut, wo du bist und ich sehe deine Taroscheiben, oder ist das so stillschweigend und du informierst dich selber?
Das ist in dem Sinne stillschweigend.
Du weißt, worauf du dich einlässt.
Das ist auch jeder Berufskraftfahrer, auf was er sich einlässt in solchen Sachen. Bloß ich sage mal, es wird halt immer schlimmer mit dieser Überwachung. Ich finde es langsam wirklich nicht mehr rechtens, weil auch im Allgemeinen jetzt, wie gesagt, überall diese Kameras oder diese Skandale bei der Bahn und überall. Ich wollte es nur einwerfen, damit es das schon länger gibt.
Jetzt erst seit 5 Jahren oder so.
Und dann kommen noch die Leute aus dem Radio und sagen, Nico, telefonierst du im Auto?
Freisprecheranlage.
Alles klar. Danke dir für eine Anruf, Nico.
Ich danke, tschüss.
Und jetzt vom LKW auf in die Büros am Telefon, ist Max, guten Abend, Max, grüß dich.
Ich kann den Nico nur zustimmen. Ich kenne auch Systeme, die mit GPS funktionieren. Und wo man ganz genau verfolgen kann, wo das Auto XYZ ist. Da gibt es Verlockdateien, da heißt es, naja, die darf der Chef nicht einsehen. Aber das liegt nur im Ermessen des Arbeitgebers.
Ob das wirklich auch eingehalten wird, aber wie schlimm ist das?
Das liegt halt genau gar nicht im Ermissen des Arbeitgebers. Also da gibt es halt einfach Vorgaben.
Nein, nein, wir haben aber die Chance, weil er dann über die Routekennung verfügt, zu sagen, naja, wir gucken rein und gucken nicht rein. Normalerweise müsste das überwacht werden, aber das passiert ja einfach gar nicht. Aber viel schlimmer ist eigentlich die Überwachung der Internetgewohnheiten der Kollegen.
Du machst einen Bürojob, hören wir da aus.
Ich habe ein ganz krasses Beispiel. Da wurde bei uns ein Kollege herausgekanntet, also ein Beamter, wegen irgendwelchen Nutzung von IT-Technik, nicht im Sinne des Auftraggebers. Und da ich selber auch Administrator bin und eigentlich über alle Zugänge verfüge, muss ich feststellen, dass Rechner durchgescannt werden, die eigentlich von vertrauenswürdigen Kollegen sind, die unter anderem auch Administratoren sind. Und da kann, wenn in einer Firma drei Administratoren sind, oder ich hab's doch nicht, guck doch mal in die Log-Datei sowieso, dann kann man ganz klar sehen, wo hat der Kollege XYZ, auf welchen Seiten, Webseiten hat er sich im Prinzip informiert. Und das kann nur verhindert werden, indem man die sogenannte Gewaltentrennung macht. Dass man sagt, ein Administrator in einer Behörde darf nicht gleichzeitig auf diese sogenannten Log-Dateien zugreifen. Da muss man dafür sorgen, dass diese Log-Dateien ausgelagert werden und dann ganz andere Kollegen im Prinzip den Zugang dafür haben. Und da muss man technische Voraussetzungen schaffen, die das im Prinzip dann auch gewährleisten. Und das ist gar nicht der Fall. Da kümmert sich doch kein Mensch drum. Und deswegen ist dieser Datenschutz Makulatur für meine Begriffe. Also ganz einfach Makulatur. Und was auch alle Vorredner gesagt haben, ist einfach Tatsache. Es gibt Datenschutzgesetze, aber es gibt kaum jemanden, der so viel Tiefgang hat in den Systemen, um das dann auch zu kontrollieren. Und da würde ich jetzt selber, indem ich rein zufällig darauf gestoßen bin, man braucht ja nur eigentlich die Befehlsequenzen, die vorhergegeben sind, die kriegt man ja über diese Historie aus. Da sieht man, ach Mensch, da hat ja einer sich gekümmert, was ja x, auf welchen Seiten er sich bewegt hat. Und das ist einfach eine Katastrophe. Also das Datenschutzgesetz ist eine feine Sache. Aber ich glaube kaum, dass das überall so intensiv auch eingehalten wird. Und wer will das kontrollieren? Die wenigsten wissen überhaupt, wo man diese Informationen findet.
Beziehungsweise wissen die wenigsten überhaupt, was allgemein los ist. Deswegen gibt es ja auch eine Sendung wie dieses Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein Thema, das man mal einsprechen müsste.
Starbuck hat eine Wortmeldung dazu.
Du hast mich jetzt schon wieder überfahren. Also nochmal zu den Log-Dateien. Von welchen Log-Dateien redest du? Ich rede zum Beispiel vom Proxy-Server.
Nein, vom Proxy-Server. Es ist ja so, wenn man in einer Firma arbeitet, dann hat man meistens, bevor man ins Internet gelangt, noch einen Server, der vorgeschaltet ist, wo im Prinzip häufig benutzte Internetseiten zwischengespeichert werden, damit man nicht ständig hier das Netz beansprucht und so viel Netzlast verursacht. Und dann kann man nachgucken, Rechner bezogen, wer hat wo, auf welchen Seiten wann gescannt.
Genau, das ist ja dann zum Beispiel schon mal wieder eine Fehlkonfiguration, wenn man das noch nachträglich nachgucken kann. Also man kann den Server, den Proxy-Server, auch genau so einrichten, dass er das nicht anzeigt, wer das getan hat.
Wer kontrolliert das?
Das ist halt im Zweifelsfall irgendwie auch deine Aufgabe als Admin, diesen Server.
Es wäre natürlich die Aufgabe von einem betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten, das ist genau seine definierte Aufgabe. Und du müsst auch einen haben, wenn du in der Behörde arbeitest.
Im Prinzip hat der überhaupt keine Peilung, wo er den Hebel ansetzen muss. So kann ich das hier in meinem Fall ganz konkret sagen. Ich möchte die Behörde nicht nennen, die eigentlich dafür verantwortlich ist, dass Gesetze eingehalten werden.
Das ist absurd.
Aber so ist die Tatsache ganz klar. Ich bin selber schockiert, dass man Leute, die wirklich die tragende Soll in der Firma sind, nicht traut, dass man da nachforscht. Und wenn ich dann vielleicht mal irgendwo zufällig gelandet bin oder Wetter berichte oder sonst was, okay, da sagt keiner was. Aber man weiß nicht, ob irgendwann, wenn man wirklich mal mitgebaut hat, ein Ding vorgelegt wird, ich sage ja, sie haben ja eigentlich in der Vergangenheit schon so viele Sachen gemacht, die gar nicht zu ihrem Dienst gehören, Dienstauftrag und so weiter. Ich will nur sagen, es ist jetzt sehr schwierig, das zu machen, weil die Systeme immer komplexer werden und kaum einer da so drinsteckt. Und wenn ein Datenschutzbeauftragter für 450 Leute verantwortlich ist, erstmal hat er gar keinen Zugang zu der IT-Stelle oder zu den Leuten, die da die Rechner administrieren. Und die, die ich da kenne, die haben zwar einen hohen Dienstgrad und sind auch im Prinzip kompetent in ihrem Bereich, aber IT ist ein anderes Thema.
Weißt du, weißt du, wer, also nochmal, um das auf den Fall jetzt irgendwie speziell einzugehen, weißt du denn, wer das nachgeprüft hat, also wer diese Überprüfung vorgenommen hat?
Da wird ein netter Kollege des Chefs angesprochen vom Chef und der macht das eigentlich, weil er oft sehr, sehr neugierig ist und auf Zuhörer wird das passiert sein unter vier Augen. Und ist auch ziemlich klar.
Du weißt aber, welcher Kollege das ist?
Ich vermute es, aufgrund der Zusammenhänge. Aber ich kann es auch nicht nachweisen, weil...
Hast du ihn mal drauf angesprochen? Also ich meine, das ist irgendwie sowas, das man unter Kollegen auch mal irgendwie ansprechen sollte.
Ja, wir sind kurz davor, darüber zu reden. Ich muss noch mit einem Betroffenen darüber reden, weil er im Urlaub ist und wenn das klar ist, werden wir den dann auch zur Brust nehmen und ihm sagen, warum er das getan hat. Also wir wollen jetzt auch keinen Chaos hier erzeugen, weil wir haben uns auch nichts vorzuwerfen, aber da gerade ein Kollege gegangen ist und keiner weiß so richtig, warum. Also richtig rausgekantet. Da bin ich ein bisschen sensibel geworden. Aber diese gesetzliche Lage, die finde ich ganz toll. Aber das umzusetzen, das ist sehr, sehr schwer. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, das ist ganz selten richtig funktioniert.
Das ist auch bei den E-Mails so.
Theoretisch kann ich als Administrator jede E-Mail lesen. Da gibt es auch eine Regel, ja, der Administrator darf aber nicht der E-Mail, der Postmeister sein. Also ich kann im Prinzip in meinem E-Mail-Server mit ihr Teil anschauen und kann lesen, was Max Mütze da geschrieben hat.
Keine Frage.
Deswegen müsste man da wirklich auch für diesen Datenbereich eine ganz andere Kennung schaffen, wo eben ein Fremder, einer wegen der Datenschutzbeauftragte, nur rein kann und kein anderer.
Also pass mal auf, Max, damit du auch mal Luft holen kannst. Sonst hyperventilierst du uns hier und musst in eine Tüte reinatmen. Nur um mal diese Frage von der anderen Seite zu stellen, wenn du sagst, da müsste es eine außergeladene Stelle geben und es muss jemand geben, der sich extern darum kümmert. Wenn ich mich jetzt in die Situation vom Chef versetzen würde, taucht vor meinen Augen eine Aufblähung des Personalapparates aus. Du baust noch mehr Bürokratie und noch mehr Bürokratie und noch mehr Bürokratie. Da gibt es eine Stelle und um die Stelle muss ich wieder jemand kümmern. Um die Stelle muss ich wieder jemand kümmern. Ist das nicht auch eine Frage an Konstanze? Wird das nicht irgendwann zu einem endlosen Fass ohne Boden, wo immer noch eine Kontrollinstanz eingebaut wird?
Natürlich ist das Problem recht komplex.
Wie kann man das handeln?
Also klar, gerade wenn man jetzt so sieht, dass eben tatsächlich die betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten oft nicht wirklich einen Überblick haben über die Datenverarbeitungssysteme. Das war Teil ihrer Aufgabe. Sie haben sogar als konkrete Aufgabe, Übersichten zu erstellen, wo gibt es welche Datenverarbeitungsanlagen. Aber wir sehen ja hier an dem praktischen Fall, den Max erzählt hat, sie haben halt irgendwie drei Admins und der betriebliche Datenschutzbeauftragte checkt da eh nicht so recht die Lage. Das ist halt klassischerweise der Fall. Und das Problem kommt dazu, dass offenbar das Unrechtsbewusstsein wenig ausgeprägt ist. Wenn der Chef also dann zu irgendeinem von dem Admin sagt, zeig mir nochmal, was hat der gemacht, dann wird das getan. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es dafür Regeln. Und also muss eine Forderung sein, wenn man das erfährt, dann muss es einen klaren Schutz von sogenannten Whistleblowern geben. Also so Leuten wie Max, die sich etwa jemanden konkret anvertrauen können. Wenn sie das nicht bei ihrem betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten können, dann können sie sich etwa an ihren Landesdatenschutz beauftragen. Dazu müsste man ein, zwei Leute haben in jedem Bundesland bei diesen Beauftragten, die echt sich darum kümmern. Das ist ein Standardproblem. Das hören wir sehr häufig.
Wie ist denn im Moment die Situation, auch die Ausstattung der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten?
Die ist natürlich in jeder Hinsicht verbesserungsfähig. Die Datenverarbeitungsanlagen sind explodiert in den letzten zehn Jahren. Die Mitarbeiterstellen haben sich überhaupt nicht erhöht. Und wenn dann marginal. Da müsste man also viel mehr machen. Denn die prüfen ja nicht nur die Behörden, sondern auch die kommerziellen Unternehmen. Und natürlich müsste man auch eine viel bessere Ausstattung fordern. Wir haben halt die betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten. Die sind für all diese zuständig. Aber oft gibt es da auch die Problematik, dass sie natürlich nicht mal freigestellt werden für ihre Tätigkeit. Oder dass sie eben auch, was die IT-Kenntnisse betrifft, nicht mithalten können. Und dass sie gar keinen Überblick haben, wer eigentlich welche Rechte und Rollen hat in den Systemen. Weil ich glaube, den Fall, den Maxi erzählt hat, der ist klassisch. Nicht nur bei Behörden, sondern auch bei kommerziellen Unternehmen.
Es gibt allerdings eine klare Regelung.
Es gibt eine sehr klare Regelung, was die Internetnutzung betrifft. Das heißt, das Bundesarbeitsgericht hat schon 2005 entschieden, dass man Arbeitnehmer fristlos kündigen kann, wenn sie privat im Netz surfen, etwa. Das kann man.
Weil sie nicht der Arbeit nachgehen, der für die sie bezahlt werden.
Genau, wenn zum Beispiel festgelegt ist, dass das nicht erlaubt ist und vor allen Dingen der Umfang in dem Urteil, dass das ausschweifend ist, dann ist das möglich. Das heißt, man muss natürlich hier auch gucken, was steht in meinem Arbeitsvertrag? Was steht in der Betriebsvereinbarung dazu? Wie viel Prozent kann ich wirklich nutzen? Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass der Arbeitgeber standardmäßig das immer checkt. Das wäre natürlich trotzdem nicht legal.
Ja, ich kann nur sagen, es ist theoretisch möglich, diese Regel einzuhalten. Aber es ist sehr viel Aufwand. Und zwar die Idee stellen die Regel natürlich dadurch, dass sich immer mehr Aufgaben auf diese Behörden, auf diese Dienststellen verlagern. Die kriegen kaum noch Luft, die haben selbst viel zu tun. Und der Datenschutzbeauftragte hat ja gar keine Chance, weil er weder über die Zugangsdaten verfügt, Zugangsdaten sind immer der, der verantwortlich ist für Systeme, für Fachverfahren, weil die den Dienstherr in den Eiern sagen, pass auf hier, warum ist jetzt dieses Problem entstanden? Und der macht dann auch entsprechende Vorkehrungen, dass eben alles funktioniert.
Der muss ja eigentlich selber machen. Also ich meine, wenn du so ein Problem hast und zum Datenschutzbeauftragten gehst, dann wird er natürlich auch auf beine Hilfe zurückgreifen und sagen, dann zeig mir das doch mal und das dann auf einen offiziellen Weg machen. Das heißt, er muss das nicht unbedingt verstehen. Er muss das grundsätzlich sehen, was das Problem ist. Aber er muss das nicht mit den Finessen des Proxys vertraut sein.
Ich glaube, man sieht hier einfach auch, dass da mehr nötig ist als eine Gesetzesänderung. Das heißt, wir brauchen auch ein Umdenken. Denn was du beschreibst, dass es gang und gäbe ist und dass es sowieso keine Peilung hat, weil viel zu tun hat und viel zu viele IT-Systeme da sind, da muss man halt auch echt in der Struktur arbeiten. Und aber auch ein bisschen an der Wahrnehmung davon, was man sich irgendwie noch vorstellen kann, ob man tut. Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Umdenken, wo ich glaube, da brauchen wir halt noch eine ganze Zeit, bis das verstanden ist.
Ich will einfach nur sagen, dass es sehr viele schöne Gesetze gibt, aber keiner so richtig prüft, inwieweit sie praxisrelevant sind. Bei diesem Gesetz ist der Denkansatz klasse, aber die Umsetzung ist sehr kompliziert. Und sie würde wirklich bedeuten, dass sich Personal aufbläht, und es ist ein teurer Spaß auch. Deswegen muss man einfach sagen, okay, wir kennen die Regeln, und wir verhalten uns entsprechend. Ansonsten kann es ein bisschen böse aussehen.
Und wenn ihr, um auf deinen Fall zurückzukommen, wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, dass bei euch in der Firma ein Whistleblower ist, dann tut manchmal vielleicht auch ein kollegales Gespräch schon... Ja, das kommt sowieso.
Aber ich habe diese Sendung gehört, auch bei den Kraftfahrern. Das hatte ich ja vorher. Da hatte ich auch so ein System, wo man einen Kraftfahrer per GPS überwacht. Und da war auch die Diskussion, was ist denn mit dieser Teil sowieso? Ja, kann man ja ganz genau sehen, der ist von A nach B gefahren, da war mal kurz im Baumarkt, hat mal einen kurzen Blick geworfen, weil er ein bisschen Laminat brauchte, und die wollten das nicht. Und ja, es war gar nicht so einfach, das so einzutakten, dass eben der Chef das nicht machen kann. Ja, gab es sehr viele Diskussionen, und am Ende hat es dann doch gekonnt, aber okay, da war dann so ein Gentleman-Decrement. Aber ich muss schon sagen, dass das bei den Kraftfahrern auch sehr, sehr schwer umzusetzen geht. Die werden ja auch getrieben, und mit acht Stunden ist da alles Illusion. Wir haben hier einen Preiskampf, da kommen Leute aus allen Jahren lindern.
Da komme ich jetzt mal um die Ecke und sage, Max, das ist schon wieder ein anderes Thema.
Durch diese Möglichkeiten, die neue Technik, kann man eigentlich die Leute immer weiter auskundschaften. Man hat im Lesen eine Bürgerwache, das ist einfach.
Lassen wir genauso stehen. Max, danke dir für den Anruf.
Ich danke auch.
Die Zeitsprechstunden.
Die Young Lovers sind das Shake the Ghost, Chaos Radio auf Fritz Nummer 143, trägt den schönen Titel, Belauscht, Bespitzelt, Abgeschnorchelt, Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer, der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast bei Fritz, Constanze und Starbucks sind da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 1 2 0 und von euren Geschichten, von eurer Arbeit oder von eurer Uni oder von euren Bewerbungen zu erzählen. Der nächste am Telefon ist Rainer, du musst jetzt ein bisschen warten, ich hoffe das ist nicht so schlimm, Name Rainer. Wo arbeitest du, wie ist es bei dir?
Ich bin im Moment nicht berufstätig und es ist noch mal eine Aussage dazu, dass es ja schon von dem Administrator angesprochen worden ist, die Gesetze erfunden wurden am grünen Tisch und praktikabel mit mehr, meistens nur mit mehr Personal und noch mehr Überwachung. Irgendwann wir überwachtigen Überwacher. Und wir hatten ja vor kurzem noch, die ging durch die Medien, dass eine Kassiererin bei Kaisers für 1, 30 Euro den Arbeitsplatz verloren hat. Im Arbeitsgericht in der zweiten Kasserserie. Und auch da wird ja überwacht, bzw. die Frage ist, die Tendenz oder alles, das wird national überwacht und das wird in der EG überwacht. Von der EG war mit eurem Mann in einer Telefonannahme, dass in Finnland jetzt noch oder jetzt wieder zusätzlich die E-Mails überwacht werden. Das ist glaube ich noch ein Zusatz von der EG oder Nachschlag geworden, dass jeweils die E-Mails auch noch mit überwacht werden sollen. Und die Frage ist eigentlich...
Meinst du Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder was meinst du?
Na, weiter also Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder Überwachung, ja.
Na ja, du meinst die sogenannte Telekom-Paket.
Und bei allen großen Firmen ist in der letzten Zeit hochgekommen, dass das Personal überwacht wird. Und die Frage ist, wenn dort in Deutschland keine geklärte Rechtslage ist, dann ist eigentlich der Vorstoß von den Arbeitgebern mit meinem Rechtsverständnis eigentlich eine strafbare Handlung. Weil sie arbeiten da im rechtsfreien Raum.
Also das ist tatsächlich für einige der großen Skandale vom letzten Jahr der Fall. Da ermitteln ja auch die Staatsanwaltschaften, ist keine Frage. Aber da sind natürlich auch ein paar Bereiche, die man so als Grauzone bezeichnen kann. Und dann gibt es halt ein paar Bereiche, zum Beispiel bei der Bahn, wo sie ja immer viel mit dieser Korruptionsbekämpfung argumentieren, die eigentlich überhaupt nicht vom Unternehmen so global gemacht werden muss. Und natürlich vom Staat, denn der Staat ist ja eigentlich der Korruptionsbekämpfer.
Da gibt es ja eigene Vereinten und Organisationen, die sich darum kümmern.
Genau, also dann sagen sie halt, wir haben ja auch 17 Leute gefangen, bei unserem eben tausendfachen Datenabgleich. Damit ist das ja ausreichend begründet. Also da wird dann ganz klar dagegen verstoßen, was Rechtslage ist. Aber eben für den einzelnen Arbeitnehmer ist das ja schwer zu überblicken. Ich habe ja vorhin mal gesagt, wie viele Gesetze man dafür kennen muss, plus die Gerichtsentscheidung. Das ist ja grad, warum er halt echt gefordert werden muss. Da brauchen wir jetzt mal klare und zwar restriktive Regeln, damit die Arbeitgeber nicht meinen, das wird jetzt hier so usus, wie das 2008 in den Medien war.
Also um Rainers Argument noch mal aufzugreifen, wer überwacht eigentlich die, die die anderen überwachen? Wir hatten gerade die Wortmeldung, dass die Datenschutzbeauftragten in den Firmen eigentlich überlastet sind, weil viel zu viel Arbeitsvolumen und viel zu viel Fach- und Detailkenntnis auf viel zu wenig Leute umgewälzt wird. Beziehungsweise, dass die Rechtslage, die im Moment besteht, undurchsichtig ist, weil es die verschiedensten Gesetze gibt und weil keiner so richtig blickt, nach welchen Richtlinien man jetzt quasi sein Unternehmen schützen kann, wenn man kontrolliert, was da passiert und wo es dann quasi in den illegalen Bereich geht. Also, wo ist denn jetzt die Instanz? Oder welche Instanz wäre denn zuständig, um sich darum zu kümmern? Außer wieder ein paar Internetausdrucker, die den Gesetze entlassen.
Also ich glaube, die Instanz ist halt irgendwie schon ganz klar. Das sind halt die Datenschützer. Also beziehungsweise die Datenschutzbeauftragte, die im Betrieb oder die Landes- oder Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten sind. Das Problem ist halt einfach, auch mehrfach schon angesprochen heute, dass sie halt personell halt so unterbesetzt sind. Also auch gerade die Landes- und Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, die haben halt wirklich 10, 20, 30 Leute. Also irgendwie halt so geringe Anzahl, dass sie sich halt maximal mit ein paar hundert Fällen im Jahr überhaupt befassen können. Also auch gerade, wenn man irgendwie ja sieht, was das für ein Volumen ist. Das heißt eigentlich muss da ganz klar sein, irgendwie die brauchen mehr Personal und wie auch klare Regelungen, um halt irgendwie solche Fälle halt einfach mal auch schnell abzuarbeiten zu können.
Es gibt natürlich eine zweite Instanz. Das wäre natürlich klassischerweise, man geht zum Anwalt, wenn man also weiß, mein Arbeitgeber hat diese oder jene grenzlegale oder illegale Überwachungsmaßnahmen gegen mich unternommen, kann man machen. Aber wir haben halt auch gesehen, dass viele, der zumindest sehr ans Licht gekommen ist, Skandale, so prekäre Arbeitsverhältnisse betreffen. Die Kassiererin von Lidl oder von Rewe wird sich selten sofort zum Anwalt begeben, weil das ist halt auch eine teure Sache. Wenn man jetzt etwa so hat, weiß ich nicht, sagen wir mal, Mobiltelefonüberwachung bei mittleren Angestellten, okay, die gehen vielleicht noch zum Anwalt. Das ist natürlich auch eine Option. Aber wir wünschten uns halt auch, und das ist eine ganz klare Forderung, auch schon seit Jahren, dass a. die Aufstattung besser wird, aber b. man auch konkrete Ansprechpartner hat in den Landesdatenschutzbehörden, wo man eben, da gibt es halt eine Nummer, da kann ich anrufen, da ist ein, zwei, drei Mitarbeiter, die sich um sowas kümmern, und zwar im Zweifel auch anonym, wenn ich halt Angst in meinem Job habe.
Also, ich würde das auf jeden Fall erstmal annehmen und irgendwie dann das weiterverfolgen. Also, genau das, was halt vorhin schon angesprochen wurde, die müssen sich halt gar nicht irgendwie mit der Materie sehr zu genau auskennen, sie müssen halt einfach wissen, dass es halt irgendwie dort ein Problem gibt und halt im Zweifel dann dann einfach mal nachforschen.
Also von offiziellerer Seite einfach Druck machen.
Es kommt halt einfach viel besser, wenn halt der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte irgendwie dann mal eine Abordnung in den Betrieb schickt und mal irgendwie fragt, also wir haben hier gehört irgendwie und können Sie mal da Zustellung nehmen. Weil die Arbeitgeber verpflichtet sind, irgendwie dann auch wirklich zu antworten und irgendwie dann die Details rauszulassen.
Und die dritte Instanz, die man da noch dazu rechnen muss, sind natürlich die Betriebsräte. Zwar sind die, wenn man einen betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten hat, nicht die so direkt zuständig, aber über die Mitbestimmungsrechte sind sie fast immer dabei. Wenn also neue Datenverarbeitungssysteme eingesetzt werden, eine neue Personaldatenverarbeitung, alles sowas, dann sind die natürlich drin und bestimmen auch die Betriebsvereinbarungen mit. Das heißt, auch da ist es so, dass wir natürlich eine Stärkung brauchen.
Vor allem auch wenn dann halt wirklich Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchgeführt werden, dann sind also wirklich, wenn diese, wenn die Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden, sind die Auftragte überverpflichtet, die Betriebsräte zu informieren, dass es stattfindet und die müssen es im Allgemeinen halt auch abnicken dann.
Das klingt unterm Strich wie ein großes Feld der Neueinstellung, der zu schaffenden Berufe. Bewerbt euch alle als Datenschutzbeauftragte. Da gibt es Arbeit ohne...
Man muss auch einige Fähigkeiten mit sich bringen. Also es gibt doch schon ein paar Anforderungen.
Ist schon klar, aber der Bedarf ist auf jeden Fall da und er kann. Rainer, danke dir für deinen Anruf. Chaosradio, hört ihr auf Fritz? 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Der nächste am Telefon ist Andreas aus Aachen. Guten Abend, Andreas. Grüß dich. Ihr seid doch in Aachen gerade in der absoluten Karnevals, im Karnevalswahnsinn, ertrunken, oder?
Ja, ich bin da sozusagen Karnevalsflüchtling gewesen. Ich hab mich in eine ruhige Region zurückgezogen.
Und ab morgen, ab Donnerstag sind die ersten Geschäfte uns wieder ansprechbar, weil heute bis Aschermittwoch alle gefeiert haben.
Ja, ne, das lief doch heute schon wieder relativ normal.
Okay, wir sehen also rosigen Zeiten entgegen der Karnevals durch. Was ist dein Begehr?
Ja, also ich hab die Frage, wenn man sich z.B. beruflich umorientieren möchte, wird man ja häufig aufgefordert, seine Bewerbungsunterlagen per PDF einzureichen. Und ja, ich hab ja immer ein etwas ungutes Gefühl, weil ich nicht weiß, was mit diesen Dateien halt im Nachhinein passiert. Werden die zentral gespeichert? Die sind dann ja im Prinzip jahrelang noch wieder aufrufbar. Und ja, ich hab mir schon mal überlegt, ob man nicht jetzt zum Beispiel so eine PDF-Datei, die kann man im Prinzip verschlüsseln, ob man dann nicht auch dann sozusagen auf einem Server, den dann derjenige das einsehen möchte, kontaktieren muss, dann sozusagen Zertifikatsabgleich macht, dass das nur ein, zwei Monate abrufbar ist, diese Datei und danach halt, ja.
Und dann kommt die Personalabteilung und sagt, ich versteh das nicht, schicken sie es mir bitte her, weil ansonsten guck ich es gar nicht erst an.
Das klingt alles schön, aber halt genauso Daten. Also wenn du sie halt einmal anzeigen kannst auf dem Bildschirm, dann hast du sie halt auch für ewig irgendwie gespeichert. Das hat das Problem an digitalen Sachen, aber es ist eine sehr interessante Frage, wie man halt mit so Daten umgeht, beziehungsweise so Löschungsfristen, beziehungsweise einfach, wie löst man überhaupt wirklich Daten?
Ja, oder habe ich das Recht zum Beispiel, das ist ja dann vielleicht nicht mein zukünftiger Arbeitgeber, das heißt, ich habe da keine rechtliche Beziehung zu dem, habe dem aber mal meine Daten geschickt, habe ich da irgendwie das Recht dann zu verlangen, dass die wirklich gelöscht werden, habe ich ein Nachprüfrecht, ob das wirklich geschehen ist.
Also du hast das Recht, irgendwie jedem, der Daten über dich speichert, irgendwie zu fragen, welche Daten er über dich speichert und es im Zweifelsfall irgendwie auch löschen zu lassen. Du kannst natürlich nicht wirklich überprüfen, das ist das Problem. Aber zumindest rein rechtlich bist du dazu berechtigt, das abzufragen und irgendwie auch die Löschung in Auftrag zu geben.
Genau, also du könntest bei der Firma, bei der du dich beworben hast, die dich da nicht genommen haben, könntest du denen einen Brief oder eine Mail schreiben und kannst darum bitten, dass deine Daten gelöscht werden.
Genau, bei Papierformen bekommt man ja dann eben seine Unterlage zurück.
Genau, oder sie fragen dich, ist es okay, wenn wir die überhalten?
Genau.
So wird das mit der Mail genauso laufen. Kannst du dich dann hinwenden, kannst du sagen, bitte weg.
Bei den Papierdatengut könnten sie natürlich auch kopieren, aber das ist zum Beispiel nicht möglich, dann solche Daten eben irgendwie mal informell weiterzuschicken.
Na gut, aber das ist natürlich auch einfach möglich. Ich weiß, auf dem Scanner habe ich auch eine Mail. Aber der Aufwand ist halt weit größer, klar.
Mir ist immer ein bestimmtes Unbehagen, wenn ich sowas dann los schicken soll. Ich würde es am liebsten immer noch per Papier machen, aber dann gucken die Leute es sich manchmal vielleicht gar nicht an, weil es so umständlich ist und sie wollen das halt auf dem Rechner am Platz haben und fertig aus, dann bin ich halt gezwungen, das halt auch auf diese Weise in die Welt zu schicken.
Ja, noch schlimmer ist es eigentlich, wenn man eben diese sogenannten freiwilligen Tests macht, also Drogentests, Gentests mittlerweile, also dass man alles mögliche, was machen dann eigentlich die Unternehmen nachher damit. Wir haben eigentlich so ein bisschen, das geht ein bisschen über den Arbeitnehmerdatenschutz hinaus, wir haben halt auch eine Idee, wie man da dem normalen Bürger, nicht nur Bewerber, sondern im Prinzip jedem Menschen, da so ein bisschen die Macht zurückkippt. Wir haben seit einiger Zeit über diese Idee des Datenbriefes nachgedacht. Der Datenbrief soll halt ein Dokument sein, was man einmal im Jahr bekommt, und zwar von all denen, die meine Daten verarbeiten. Das sind natürlich dann so einige Briefe bei erwachsenen Menschen, die ein Bankkonto haben. Aber man könnte die halt gleichzeitig zusammen mit Vertragsunterlagen oder eben mit Werbung, die man ja ohnehin bekommt.
Wo du eine Übersicht hast über die Dinge, die gespeichert sind.
Das hat genau das, was du halt gerade angefragt hast, von der anderen Seite aufgezogen, dass jeder verpflichtet ist, per Gesetz genau zu schreiben, wenn er Daten über dich hat, und halt auch genau zu sagen, welche, und im Zweifel auch irgendwie mit dem Ankreuzbriefchen irgendwie, ich soll die Daten irgendwie erzöschen.
Ich hab schon mal den Trick gemacht, wenn ich irgendwo meine Daten zu Werbezwecken, die ich also speziell anfordere, dann angeben muss, dass ich dann irgendwie noch einen zweiten Vornamen zurückgehe. Und dann weiß ich halt, wo die herkommen. Und dann kann ich denen entsprechend, wenn es dann da kommt, anhauen, warum hast du meine Daten weitergegeben.
Na gut, aber hast du das schon mal getan? Oder hast du das schon mal aufgetreten?
Nee, ist noch nicht aufgetreten. Aber wie gesagt, ich habe dann eben von der Firma, wo ich dann direkt das erste Mal angefordert habe, habe ich dann halt mir so eine Notiz gemacht, wer das eben mit diesem entsprechenden Kürzel hat. Und wenn da eben was käme, also bis jetzt habe ich Glück gehabt, weil ich das auch sehr selten halt mache und nicht jedem meine Daten halt gebe und was anfordere. Und auch eigentlich meistens an für mich vertrauenswürdige Stellen. Aber wenn eben so was passieren würde, habe ich halt die Möglichkeit, das dann nachzuvollziehen.
Was war es genau denn deine Befürchtung? Also wenn es halt so um Bewerbungsunterlagen geht, warum willst du denn nicht, dass dein Arbeitgeber oder dein Nicht-Arbeitgeber irgendwie noch Daten über dich hat, die du ihm mal gegeben hast?
Ja, ich habe es schon mal so auf weiter Ferne gehört von Bekannten, dass dann mal schnell, wenn irgendwie ein Bewerber zum Beispiel zum Vorstellungsgespräch kommt, dass er dann halt mal schnell die Bewerbungsdaten nochmal eben irgendwo rüber geschickt werden. Es könnte natürlich jetzt sein, dass jemand irgendwie, der mir nicht gut will, meine Bewerbung, die ich irgendwo hinschicke, irgendjemandem schickt, bei dem ich noch in Arbeit bin zum Beispiel, guckt mal an und dann entweder um mich da rauszuhauen oder was weiß ich. Man könnte ja mit diesen Daten, wenn man jetzt erfährt, ich schaue mich um, ich bin noch in der Beschäftigung, könnte das natürlich irgendwo wieder ankommen.
Beziehungsweise du kannst aber andersrum, wenn du dich bewirbst, in der Bewerbung darum bitten, die Daten vertraulich zu behandeln, da du noch in einem Arbeitsverhältnis bist.
Davon gehe ich normalerweise auch aus, dass das jeder, den ich anschreibe, dann macht. Aber durch die technischen Gegebenheiten ist das viel einfacher möglich, vielleicht sowas dann eben zu verteilen.
Wäre natürlich unangenehm jetzt für deine jetzige Arbeitsverhältnis, wenn das bekannt würde, klar. Aber ich glaube natürlich, in Wirklichkeit musst du natürlich nicht begründen, warum du das nicht möchtest.
Ja, genau.
Und ich habe gedacht, wenn es irgendwie eine gangbare technische Möglichkeit gäbe, das für eine bestimmte Zeit nur einsehbar zu machen. Natürlich kann man es immer kopieren, vom Bildschirm, dem Screenshot, alles.
Das ist die Frage, die wir uns allgemein stellen. Das Problem, dass man gesellschaftliche Probleme nicht mit technischen Möglichkeiten oder Lösungen bearbeiten sollte.
Die Menschen müssen es entsprechend ausführen, sich an Rechte und Ordnung halten.
Du musst ein Grundbewusstsein für Datenschutz geschaffen werden. Das sind deine Daten. Du hast das Recht, über das Verteilen dieser Daten zu bestimmen.
Du musst ein Bewusstsein haben, dass du überhaupt Daten verteilst. Wenn dir Krümel aus der Jackentasche fallen, werden sie irgendwo auf der Straße liegen. Ich werde wissen, wo du warst.
Glaubst du, dass so ein Datenbrief, wie er jetzt vorgeschlagen wurde, eine Idee wäre, die auch die Unternehmen irgendwie incentiviert, dass sie die Daten freiwillig löschen, weil dann brauchen sie ja keine Datenbriefe raus schicken? Meinst du, das könnte was helfen?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich auch, wer kontrolliert, dass jedes Unternehmen das wirklich dann auch macht.
Du bist nicht der Betroffene. Du kriegst ja Datenbriefe, wenn du keinen kriegst.
Wenn ich nicht kriege, dann könnte ich natürlich dem sagen, warum hast du mir keinen geschickt? Dann hätte der schon Ärger.
Das ist eine Frage der Strafen nicht, wenn die Strafen halt irgendwie ausreichend hoch angesetzt sind, wenn sie das nicht tun.
Das ist eh noch mal eine Sache, die wir hier natürlich nicht genügend angesprochen haben. Wir wünschen uns natürlich auch für die zukünftige Gesetzgebung einfach eine harte Sanktionierung, damit eben diese kavalierendste Leakgehabe auf...
Zu Hubs tut uns leid, ist passiert.
Das ist das, was man dann an Gewinnen auch daran hat.
Andreas, danke dir für den Einwand mit den Bewerbungen. Das hatten wir heute noch nicht in der Sendung. Danke schön.
Wir werden es mal verfolgen mit dem Datentrieb. Das ist eine interessante Idee.
Alles klar. Chaosradio auf Fritz, 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute über den Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Also im günstigsten Fall für euch oder an eurer Uni oder wo ihr sonst irgendwie unterwegs seid. Bespitzelt, Belauscht, Abgeschnorchelt heißt die Sendung, wenn der Chef eure Mails mitliest und die Kamera beobachtet, wenn ihr aufs Klo geht. Der nächste am Telefon ist Daniel aus Berlin. Hallo Daniel, guten Abend.
Hallöchen.
Hallo. Wo arbeitest du oder was arbeitest du?
Also ich bin mittlerweile ganz woanders. Ich habe aber vor zwei Jahren noch in der Internetagentur gearbeitet und wir haben auch so ein bisschen Netzwerkbetreuung für Firmen gemacht. Und ich war da so als technischer Berater unterwegs und war dann halt bei dem einen Chef von der Firma, der dann gesagt hat, du, wir haben hier so einen Dienst und ich würde ganz gerne wissen, weil der Geld kostet, wie der denn von dem und den Mitarbeitern genutzt wird. Die hatten also so ein schönes Büronetzwerk, Einrichtungen mit festen IP-Adressen, wo man also auch ganz leicht per IP-Adresse den Arbeitsplatz zuweisen konnte. Und ich habe mir dann mal so Gedanken gemacht, wie viel eigentlich diese Sicherheitseinrichtungen, die wir da so implementiert haben, eigentlich an Daten sammelt und was man dann an alles sehen kann. Und im Prinzip interessiert sich da keiner für, es sei denn, es gibt ein Problem.
Das heißt, hast du die erst installiert oder dann nachgedacht?
Das Ding ist ja, das kommt dazu, man installiert halt Software, meistens dann natürlich auf dem Source-Bereich, weil es schön günstig ist. Und dann sind halt irgendwelche Pakete in der Standard-Konfiguration so ausgelegt, dass sie halt erstmal mitloggen. Und das, was man halt eben sieht, hat dann dem Auftraggeber, dem Chef sozusagen, dem Erteilungsleiter erstmal zeigen können. Also ich habe natürlich erstmal selber geguckt, bevor ich ihm irgendwas gezeigt habe. Und ich habe dann halt festgestellt, weil er wollte halt von seinem Arbeitsplatz und von zwei anderen das noch wissen, ob die diesen Dienst halt nutzen.
Und vom Computer seiner Frau vermutlich?
Nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein, das war in der Firma, nicht zu Hause. Aber wie ich dann halt gesehen habe, ist er dann halt auch nachts auf irgendwelchen oder abends auf irgendwelchen Porno-Seiten unterwegs gewesen.
Und das hat man nicht strafbar?
Nein, das ist nicht strafbar. Was mich dann erstmal zum Schmunzeln gebracht hat, wo ich ihn dann halt gefragt habe, ob er wirklich möchte, dass ich das sozusagen so mitlogge. Dass er das auswerten kann, weil man da eben auch Dinge sieht, die man vielleicht nicht sehen möchte.
Aber hey, das ist dann für eine Betriebsparty oder für ein Geburtstagsgeschenk für den Chef total praktisch.
Total praktisch. Was wir dann später in einem anderen Projekt gemacht haben, wo es um Anonymität geht, das heißt, wo wir eine Webseite oder ein Portal gebastelt haben, wo man sich also anonym beraten lassen kann, wo das halt ein Problem war, weil wir uns halt auch intensiv mit Datenschutz beschäftigt haben. Ansonsten, wenn man so eine Webseite aufbaut, dann ist da halt ein Apache Web Server, der hat halt einfach standardmäßig seine Logfiles, die halt mitlaufen, wo IP-Adressen mitgehalten werden, was man sich anguckt etc. Weil der Kunde will ja auch sehen, wer hat wo zugegriffen und wie viele Leute waren da und da ist so was natürlich eine IP-Adresse natürlich sehr hilfreich.
Aber ist ja schon ein Unterschied, ob der Kunde jetzt irgendwie, also ich sag nicht Bespitzelt, sondern ob der Betreiber jetzt was über das Kundenverhalten wissen will oder irgendwie das Verhalten der eigenen Mitarbeiter. Also ist halt schon deutlich konfigurierbar, das so einzustellen, dass halt genau diese Daten für Mitarbeiter nicht anfallen und ich meine, wenn du da technischer Berater warst, dann hättest du da irgendwie eigentlich irgendwie da deinen Senf zu abgeben können müssen.
Ja klar, in der Form, dass man halt sagen kann, also in dem Fall war es dann sogar relativ einfach. Der wollte dann, es war ein Dienst, der über FDP erreichbar war. Das heißt, da hätte man also ganz klar sagen können, okay, wir wollen diesen IP-Adressbereich über den und den Port, da wollen wir wissen, was da passiert, weil dann sieht man halt eben genau, was da kommt. Aber ich musste mir halt erstmal die ganzen Logfiles angucken, um überhaupt zu sehen, wo geht das genau hin und die entsprechenden Leute rausfiltern, um die es ging, sodass man also natürlich erstmal mit dem gesamten Logfall eben zu tun hat. Aber worum es mir eben geht, ist, also wir haben dann noch ein anderes Beispiel, eben für dieses Beratungsportal, tatsächlich den Apache von der Konstruktion her, also vom Logfall-Konstruktion anpassen müssen, damit er eben die IP-Adresse nicht mitschreibt, weil es ja hier um eben entsprechend anonymes Angebot ging.
Ja, aber das sollte halt eigentlich standardmäßig so betrieben werden. Also die Forderung ist ja irgendwie, Daten, die nicht wirklich sinnvoll oder nützlich sind, halt einfach gar nicht erst zu erheben. Und das heißt, wenn man halt so einen Apache aufsetzt, dann halt irgendwie gleich beim ersten Mal erst mal die Kommando-Zeitung, die die Option irgendwie rauskommentieren, dass halt diese Logs erst angelegt werden. Weil die braucht man normalerweise nicht. Beziehungsweise kann sie halt dann irgendwie einkompilieren, wenn sie halt wirklich zur Fehleranalyse oder sowas gebraucht werden.
Ich hab den Eindruck, dass deine Message eigentlich eher ist, dass man ja so diese Default-Einstellungen, von denen man manchmal gar nicht weiß. Genau. Ja, ist schon klar, was du sagen willst.
Ist natürlich ein guter Hinweis. Ich muss erstmal rein und muss es auskommentieren. Und für die meisten Betreiber ist es eigentlich irrelevant. Es gibt ja auch andere Möglichkeiten, um herauszukriegen, wie viele Leute meine Webseite besuchen. Und da gibt es eben zu wenig Hilfsmittel, um das eben auch sinnvoll umsetzen zu können. Weil letzten Endes ist es ja so, dass viele Leute jetzt sowas einsetzen, die eigentlich nicht so wirklich Ahnung davon haben. Und die froh sind, dass die Standardkonfiguration für sie schon so funktioniert.
Okay, aber normalerweise, wenn keiner auf die Daten zugräft, dann ist es ja auch nicht wirklich ein Problem.
Sie fallen ja aber trotzdem an. Begehrlichkeiten gibt es ja dann immer irgendwo.
Das ist mit der Schielerdatei ja letzten Endes auch so. Also wenn keiner auf die Daten zugräft, ist das ja eigentlich okay.
Ja, ich muss da sagen, ich muss da auf Starbuck jetzt mal direkt widersprechen. Also die Forderung ist ja schon lange. Und das gilt für Arbeitnehmerdaten, wie im Prinzip für jedes Apache Logging. Datensparsame Systeme sind einfach mal toll. Weil dann hat man nachher nicht den Ärger mit den Datenskandalen, wenn sie abhanden kommen. Man hat nicht den Ärger, wenn jemand plötzlich, und seit vor allem der Chef, der noch irgendwie weisungsbefugt ist, sagt, du ich werde da mal ran. Also man kann natürlich auch die eigenen Daten in dem Fall jetzt noch mitschützen, wenn man selber arbeitet. Also das klassische Win-win-win-win-situation.
Und alle sind glücklich. Auch Daniel, danke dir für den Anruf.
Ich finde den Hinweis auch sehr gut. Den sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch mal im Hinterkopf behalten, dass man eben darauf achtet und nicht so eben die Forderung immer so mitnimmt.
Danke Daniel, tschüss. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr im Chaosradio. Danach geht es weiter unter anderem mit Tim, der was zum Thema Überwachung in Schulen von Schülern sagen will. Das wird spannend.
Für ihren großen Auftritt bei der Fritznacht der Talente.
Die Fritznacht der Talente.
Und wunderlichen Wortspielen.
Ich sag ich und ihr schreibt Loser. Was?
Ist... Das Publikum.
Wir.
Die Fripsnacht der Talente.
Zum sechsten Mal und im Großen Saal.
Format Miralspalast Berlin. Samstag.
21.
März.
Solang es doch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt.
Die sechste Fripsnacht der Talente.
Übertragen wir natürlich auch live und im Radio.
Und das wird. Mit Flip Burger. In Berlin sind neue schwere Fälle von Kindesmisshandlungen bekannt geworden. Seit gestern Abend musste die Polizei neun verwahrloste und verprügelte Kinder vor ihren Eltern retten und sie dem Kindernotdienst übergeben. Die Kinder waren zwischen zwei und dreizehn Jahre alt. Die Sprecherin des Kindernotdienstes Köhnen sagte der deutschen Presseagentur, alle ihre Häuser in Berlin seien voll. Nach einer Statistik mussten im letzten Jahr 2700 Kinder und Jugendliche eine Zeit lang bei Notdiensten unterkommen. Bei einem Flugzeugabsturz auf dem Amsterdamer Flughafen sind neun Menschen getötet worden. Rund 80 Passagiere wurden verletzt, davon 25 schwer. Die in Istanbul gestartete Maschine befand sich im Landeranflug, als sie auf einem Acker aufschlug und in drei Teile zerbrach. Die Unlucksursache gibt Rätsel auf, da kein Feuer ausbrach. Deshalb wird darüber spekuliert, ob in dem Flugzeug das Kerosin ausgegangen sein könnte. In Berlin haben Jugendliche gegen die Schülerdatei protestiert. Allerdings fiel die Demo deutlich kleiner aus als geplant. Die Initiative Bildungsblockaden einreißen hatte auf bis zu 1000 Teilnehmer gehofft. Es kamen weniger als 100. Die Schülerdatei kommt Mitte März. In ihr werden 16 Daten von jedem Berliner Schüler gespeichert, wie zum Beispiel Anschrift und Muttersprache. In kleinen Berliner Kneipen darf ab dem 1. Mai wieder geraucht werden. SPD und Linke unterschrieben den Entwurf für ein geändertes Nichtraucherschutzgesetz. Geraucht werden darf in solchen Raucherlokalen aber nur, wenn niemand unter 18 Jahren reinkommt und es keine Küche gibt, die frisches Essen serviert. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte die Anti-Rauch-Gesetze von Berlin und Baden-Württemberg gekippt, deshalb mussten die Länder sie überarbeiten. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Bayern München auswärts bei Sporting Lissabon 5 zu 0 gewonnen. Das Rückspiel im Achtelfinale steigt am 10. März. In der Deutschen Eishockey-Liga haben die Berliner Eisbären gute Chancen, die Vorrunde zu gewinnen. Die Eisbären siegten im Nachholspiel gegen Adler Mannheim 7 zu 2. In der Tabelle führt Berlin jetzt 4 Punkte vor den Hannover Skorpions. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neuropin, Angermünde und Cottbus und Wittenberge und auch Frankfurt melden 4 Grad, Potsdam und Berlin 5 Grad. Heute Nacht sind dichte Wolken am Himmel. Ab Mitternacht kann es über dem Haveland und später dann überall in Berlin und Brandenburg kräftig regnen. Am Donnerstag bekommen wir neben einigen Schauern auch viel Wind und es wird 7 Grad kram. Keine Störungen von den Bundesstraßen und Autobahnen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremmen.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Blum. Ihr seid auf Fritz im Chaos Radio Nummer 143. Willkommen. Starbuck ist hier, Konstanz ist hier von Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranze. Wir reden heute über Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer und drehen das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen runter. Wir haben viel über Betriebe geredet und über Firmen. Jetzt reden wir mal über die Schulen, weil Tim ist am Telefon. Hallo Tim, grüß dich.
Wo gehst du zur Schule?
Und wie ist es bei euch? Gibt es da auch schon Verdachtsmomente, dass ihr abgeschnüffelt werdet?
Ja, ich hole jetzt mal aus. Wir haben jetzt seit zwei Jahren einen neuen Informatiklehrer an der Schule, der dann auch mal direkt, als er angefangen ist, hat sich mal ein schönes Netzwerk aufgebaut und auch mal ein schönes WLAN. Ja, und wie das halt so ist, man geht mit seinem Laptop in die Schule, hat dort ein WLAN, das muss natürlich dann erst mal schön geklackt werden, weil man möchte ja auch in den Freistunden mal ein bisschen surfen dürfen.
Ein verständliches Begehr.
Ja, natürlich. Und dann kam auf einmal, also der Informatiklehrer hat sich so einen kleinen, kleines Räumchen eingerichtet, wo an seinem Haupt-PC, eine Abschnorchel-Büro-Tür zum Abschließen. Ja, ungefähr, wo er dann ein PC hat mit vier Monitoren, wo er dann den kompletten Inhalt alleine der Interneträume sieht. Plus noch ein Ding, wo einfach nur die Konsolenfenster auf sind, wo er sieht, welcher Traffic wo langgeht, von den ganzen IPs her.
Alles niffen, ja?
Ja, und wir haben jetzt auch noch schöne E-Mails von der Schule, die da natürlich viel schöner aussehen als solche Web-DE-Adressen.
Ach so, als E-Mail-Adresse verstehe, ja.
Und man wird ja jetzt auch vor den Lehren immer geraten, man sollte bitte doch die benutzen bei irgendwelchen Bewerbungen.
Habt ihr noch keine E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
Doch, aber die werden halt da... Nee, oder? Nee, ist sogar ohne Verschlüsselung.
Muss man mal, muss man sich mal klicken, aber...
Aber immer im einem App benutzt auch. Also die Daten bleiben schön noch drauf.
Das hilft nicht für den Inhalt, der mir... Das heißt, dein Verdacht ist, dass der leichte, voyeuristisch veranlagt ist oder einfach ein erhöhtes Kontrollbedürfnis hat?
Also ist das nur ein Verdacht, oder?
Nee, man hat ihn ein paar Mal geärgert und irgendwie hat er dann angefangen total zufrieden zu werden und hat dann angefangen damit und es hat schon ein paar Leute schon gesehen. Man stand da schon mal hinter ihm, als man den ganzen Traffic dort gesehen hat.
Aber ist das nicht auch, wir hatten ja vorhin die Geschichte aus der IT-Firma, ist das nicht auch was, womit man zum Vertrauenslehrer oder im Zweifelsfall zum Direktor geht und sagt, Herr So-und-So, wir glauben, dass der Kollege Informatik-Lehrer da Dinge tut, die wir nicht lustig finden, können wir mal zu einer Aussprache bitten?
Ja, aber ich glaube so, wenn der Direktor ist, geht so gut auf die 60.
Er muss ja gar nicht Ahnung haben. Er muss ja einfach nur wissen, dass ihr ein Problem mit einem bestimmten Lehrer habt und dass es da eine Aussprache gibt. Dass der Direktor nicht wissen muss, wo man die Lokfels findet, das finde ich jetzt nicht so dramatisch. Aber er ist der Chef von deinem Informatik-Lehrer.
Ja, na klütt, natürlich, aber er will ja jetzt auch nicht wirklich, dass wir da die ganze Zeit nur irgendwelche Blödsinn machen.
Das ist ja eine ganz allgemeine Frage. Es geht ja nicht darum, was ihr wirklich tut, sondern es geht darum, dass ein Lehrer unerlaubterweise tatsächlich in den Datenstrom irgendwie einen Blick hat. Also ganz unabhängig davon, was halt wirklich in den Datenstrom drin ist, ist das einfach mal illegal und irgendwie, deswegen sollte euer Weg auf jeden Fall zum Vertrauenslehrer erstmal gehen oder irgendwie dann direkt zum Direktor.
Oder zum Elternbeirat oder wer auch immer da zuständig ist, um das dann ähnlich wie bei den großen Firmen über Datenschutzbeauftragten erstmal zu klären. Weil dich hinzustellen und zu sagen, ich finde das alles doof, das ändert ja nicht. Was habt ihr dagegen unternommen?
Wir haben uns jetzt bei uns in der Stufe zusammengelegt und uns einen schönen UMTS-Stick gekauft. Wir haben jetzt immer so ein paar Leute, der Stick liegt direkt bei uns. Wir haben im Keller noch einen kleinen Proberaum, der von ein paar Leuten benutzt wird. Und der liegt jetzt dort immer. Und es gibt so ein paar Leute, die sich ein bisschen auskennen und die haben jetzt mal das UMTS-Internet offen.
Na gut, aber da ist natürlich die Geschwindigkeit ein bisschen lame, wenn das sehr viele Leute nutzen.
Ja, unabhängig davon. Ihr habt ja schon irgendwo auch die Pflicht, den Leuten, die nicht so auskennen, zu vermitteln, dass es da ein Problem gibt, bzw. direkt auch was gegen das Problem zu tun. Und nicht eure eigene Sache zu machen und euch dann gemütlich in die Ecke zu setzen und selber braun zu klicken.
Ja, ich finde auch. Also ist schon so, dass ihr da auch Verantwortung habt für eure Mitschüler.
Also in der SV haben wir es schon ein bisschen umgetreten, dass wir jetzt hier so ein paar Sticks verteilen werden. Und es läuft auch mehr oder weniger.
Ihr könntet aber auch mal rumtreten in der SV, dass ihr da zu einer Aussprache mit dem Lehrer kommen wollt.
Ja, es wird auch noch nebenbei gemacht.
Ich meine, man muss halt einfach mal ganz klar sagen, wie das er sich dort illegal verhält. Das ist irgendwie ein Fakt. Und jetzt irgendwie da außen rum zu manövrieren, ist zwar für euch vielleicht ganz nett und gut und schön, aber...
Aus sportlicher Sicht betrachtet auch Kompliment. So, einfach einen anderen Weg gewählt, aber es löst das Problem noch nicht.
Ja, aber das Problem ist ja, dass gerade diese Überwachungsprogramme in Informatikräubern, die sind auch schon... Also das, was ich jetzt auch von anderen Schulen bei uns in der Gegend kenne, das sind die einfach auch in der Tagesordnung.
Aber das macht es doch nicht wirklich besser. Ich meine, genau deswegen, weil die halt überall sind, müsstet ihr irgendwie einfach mal jetzt anfangen und das irgendwie dann im Zweifel auch irgendwie an die große Glocke hängen.
Ja, und wenn es bei eurer Schule ist, und es gibt noch mehrere Schulen im Umkreis, dann kannst du die anderen Schülervertretungen auch rufen und kannst wunderbar mit 1.000, 2.000, 3.000 Schülern dich an die zuständigen Direktoren wenden und kannst sagen, so nicht.
Aber hat da bisher noch keiner irgendwie angefangen?
Ja, mach doch mal.
Bei den Informatikräumen...
Na, was das denn für eine Ausrede?
Komm mal, Tim, du bist jetzt gefordert.
Ich frage jetzt einfach nur gerade so, weil das...
Das ist schon klar, also das ist natürlich nicht einfach.
War mir bisher noch nicht so bekannt, dass es in den Informatikräumen... Ist mir jetzt gerade so eingefallen, dass da auch dieses nette Programm drauf ist.
Ja, dann mach doch mal am Bude, ihr habt doch sicher auch eine Schülerzeitung, wo man das mal schreiben kann, ihr habt ein schwarzes Brett, wo man es anlageln kann.
Man muss natürlich ein bisschen auseinanderhalten. Ihr habt natürlich als Schüler gewisse Rechte, dieses Netz zu benutzen, etwa zur Kommunikation, zur Informationsgewinnung. Eine andere Sache ist, wenn natürlich ein Informatiklehrer in seinem Unterricht sicherstellt, dass ihr etwa nicht im Informatikunterricht surft, weil er das unterbinden will, das kann er tun.
Gerade Quake Live mal ausprobieren, was er als Browser geht.
Genau, er kann Chat unterbinden, wenn er will.
Das ist aber ein Unterschied, ob man es unterbindet oder ob man überwacht, was geklickt hat.
Aber auch in Freistunden sind diese Räume offen. Man hat den Output von dem Monitor.
Also die Aussage ist ganz klar, es geht Ihnen überhaupt gar nichts an, was ihr da tut, während eurer Freizeit, während eurer Freistunden. Wenn er da Programme installiert, dann ist das rechtswidrig gewesen und dann hat er es gefälligst zu unterlassen.
Denn auch das Fernmeldegeheimnis, das würde ja hier betroffen sein, zumindest bei den E-Mails, ist natürlich auch für Minderjährige, für Schüler, für alle. Also wert euch mal.
Ich glaube, du hast einen Termin beim Schülersprecher und bei der Schülervertretung und bei der Elternvertretung und demnächst ist der Direktor dein neuer Freund.
Und wir hätten gerne die Ergebnisse, die du da irgendwie da herausziehst, irgendwie als kleinen Artikel an die Datensteuerer geschickt. Das ist einfach ein Thema, was wirklich viele Leute interessiert. Und wenn du irgendwie da Ergebnisse zu hast, dann irgendwie einen kurzen Text, so irgendwie 5000 Zeichen oder sowas, ds.ed. ccc.de und wir freuen uns und drucken das dann auch garantiert ab. Super Tim, vielen Dank.
Eigentlich führt der Weg dann aber wirklich über den Direktor, ne?
Unterschiedlich, also wenn man natürlich jetzt irgendwie weiß, es kann ja mal dieselbe Person sein, gibt's ja auch, aber wenn man weiß, dass man da wenig Chancen hat, wenn man etwa seinen Direktor schon kennt, man kann auch noch eine Etage höher gehen, nämlich zum Landesratenschutzbeauftragten, kann man natürlich machen.
Wenn man eine gute Elternvertretung hat.
Elternvertretung, Schülervertretung, da gibt's halt wirklich viele Ansprechpartner.
Man darf halt nicht über 10 hinaus schießen. Man muss halt sehen, sich vorher ein bisschen kundig machen. Da hilft zum Beispiel, wenn man den Landesratenschutzbeauftragten mal fragt. Die geben nämlich auch Rechtsauskünfte.
Hallo Stefan, guten Abend. Hallo, wo arbeitest du?
Ich mache Mitarbeiterbefragung zum Thema Arbeitsklima. Allerdings, das Thema, die Story, die ich hier zum Besten geben will, ist ein paar Jahre her.
Da habe ich noch etwas ganz anderes gemacht.
Ach schade, ist ja interessant. Na gut, erzähl mal.
Ja, Mitarbeiterfragen, können wir später noch dazu kommen. Heute ist ja das Bewusstsein, das merken wir auch, wenn wir Mitarbeiter befragen zu einem eigentlich positiven Thema, sehr groß und Überwachung ist sehr wohl ein Thema und beeinflusst auch sehr wohl das Verhalten von Menschen an den Arbeitsplätzen.
Das macht mich aber echt total glücklich. Da würde ich gerne mal die Ergebnisse nachher noch hören, aber erzähl mal erstmal deinen Freund.
Ja, www.betriebsklima.de, kannste mal gucken. So, jetzt aber die Story. Die ist ungefähr neun bis zehn Jahre her. Zu der Zeit war das alles noch überhaupt kein Thema. Folgender Sachverhalt, ein guter Freund von mir, damals Manager unterer Ebene bei einem internen IT-Dienstleister einer großen Versicherung, war mit dem Problem konfrontiert, dass bei ihm ständig in der Abteilung Hardware geklaut wurde. Und zwar ziemlich hässlich, sodass die Kollegen auch wirklich mit Datenverlust zu kämpfen hatten. War ja damals alles noch etwas ne andere Technik. Wenn halt mal ne Festplatte geklaut war, dann war das mit dem Backup schon mal so ne Sache. Und man konnte dem Dieb nicht auf die Schliche kommen. Und die ganze Atmosphäre war vergiftet. Ist das ein Kollege, ist das einer vom Wachstum usw. Kurz und gut.
Jeder misstraut jedem.
Jeder misstraut jedem. So, er hat dann, wie ich später herausstelle, einen schweren Fehler begangen. Er hat nämlich zusammen mit zwei ihm vertrauenswürdig erscheinenden Mitarbeitern heimlich Kameras installieren lassen, die damals noch mit sehr schlechter Auflösung sozusagen so einen kleinen Stream aufgezeichnet haben, um den oder die Diebe zu überführen. Da wusste also niemand vorn außer diesen Manager und seinen zwei Mitarbeitern. Die haben das auch geschafft zum Leidwesen aller. Es war ein Kollege. Diesen Kollegen haben sie zur Rede gestellt. Und wie gesagt, waren keine Kleinigkeiten an Diebstellen, sondern schon richtig fett. Die Sache konnte auch nicht unter der Decke gehalten werden. Also dieser Kollege wurde gekündigt. Auch unter allgemeinem Beifall fand auch jeder richtig. So, jetzt komme ich ins Spiel. Ich hatte dann meinen Freund dann zu beraten, denn diese Aktion hatte für ihn übelste arbeitsrechtliche Konsequenzen. Der Arbeitnehmer wollte ihn ganz konkret deswegen kündigen. Das konnte dann unter tätigem Einsatz der Kollegen und des Betriebsrates, man höre uns staunen, also der Betriebsrat musste sozusagen dafür kämpfen, dass ein heimlicher Überwacher nicht gefeuert wird, konnte dann abgewendet werden, aber es war nicht sehr schön. Also von Gehaltskürzung über Strafversetzung, also you name it, hat der Mann reichlich Probleme gehabt und hat sich auch ziemlich schlecht hinterher gefühlt. So nach dem Wort, ich mache hier einen guten Einsatz für alle und kriege dafür noch eins auf den Deckel.
Nicht nur das, das Recht war ja in diesem Fall auch ganz klar auf seiner Seite.
Da sind wir wieder am Anfang mit dem Verdachtsmoment.
Ja, ja, ich höre die Frage, das Recht war ganz klar auf seiner Seite. Damals war das eben alles noch nicht so klar. Und hätte nicht sein Betriebsrat und seine Kollegen, vor allem seine Mitarbeiter, hätten die nicht sehr stark für ihn Partei ergriffen, dann wäre das für ihn übel ausgegangen. Und da ist natürlich auch, vor allem dann auch intern, die ganze Frage Datenschutz, Privatsphäre ziemlich diskreditiert worden. Das verstand natürlich keiner, dass sowas nicht in Ordnung sein sollte.
Also das Urteil dazu, ich hätte das vorhin schon mal besprochen, mit der Videoüberwachung, ist tatsächlich schon von 2004. Aber das hat sich natürlich auch, ja okay, aber es spricht sich auch nur ein bisschen langsamer rum, kommt noch dazu.
Also das Problem ist halt einfach, dass er, wie gesagt, dass er den Betriebsrat bzw. die zuständigen Stellen informiert hätte, dann wäre das halt rechtlich abgesichert gewesen. Und wenn er es halt nicht mit dem Betriebsrat abstimmt, dann hat er einfach mal illegal gehandelt. Das ist halt nichts von der Hand zu weisen. Das mag zwar zum Ergebnis geführt haben, aber er hat sich einfach nicht an die Sachen gehalten. Und ich meine, gut, in dem Fall haben sie jetzt den Dieb gefunden, aber sie haben trotzdem halt massiv die Rechte der anderen Mitarbeiter in dem Fall beeinträchtigt.
Naja, wie gesagt, ein konkreter Verdacht lag vor, dann ist das doch okay für einen begrenzten Zeitraum.
Ja, wenn man den Betriebsrat informiert. Und wenn er das getan hätte, dann hätte er auch keinen Ärger gekriegt.
Hinterher ist man immer schlauer. Wie gesagt, es kam diese extreme Misstrauensituation dazu. Und die Sorge, dass der Betriebsrat nicht so ganz dicht hält, da spielen dann ja auch menschliche Beziehungen zwischen Leuten, die so ein Drittel ihres Lebens miteinander verbringen.
Das mag ja alles richtig sein, aber trotzdem kann man sich ja deswegen nicht über Gesetze hinwegsetzen, nur weil man genau solche Befürchtungen hat.
Heute ist die Sache einigermaßen klar. Ich wollte mir mal zum Besten geben, dass diese Entwicklung oder das, was heute zum Teil aufliegt, möglicherweise seine Wurzeln in Zeiten hat, als das Bewusstsein noch ein anderes war. Und dass wir vielleicht gerade erleben, wie mit einem erheblichen Timelag, wie das bei Menschen immer so ist, da eine Bewusstseinsänderung stattfindet.
Das ist natürlich ein guter Hinweis. Mich freut ohnehin, dass du das sozusagen diagnostiziert hast, dass sich da viel verändert hat. Weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir weiterkommen, wenn nicht auch die Leute, also der Durchschnittsarbeitnehmer, sagen wir mal dafür, genauso wie der Durchschnittsbürger, ein Gefühl hat. Jetzt sag doch mal das Ergebnis von deiner Arbeit.
Also wir machen anonyme und wie ich meine datenschutzrechtlich äußerst vorbildliche Mitarbeiterbefragung zum Thema Arbeitsklima in allen möglichen Organisationen.
Wenn ich das in der Zwischenzeit richtig gesehen habe, seid ihr so eine Art Unternehmensberatung?
Ja, wir machen das neben sozusagen das Ehrenamtlichprojekt nebenbei, dass auch Wissenschaftler dabei, eine Hochschule dabei, eine Gewerkschaft, ein Arbeitgeberverband, also was.
Also die Juden.
Ja, davon muss man aber natürlich erst mal die Leute überzeugen. Es ist keineswegs so, dass wir überall offene Türen einrennen. Die Arbeitnehmer, wenn sie begriffen, da worum es geht, finden das zwar sehr gut und auch Betriebsräte helfen uns da. Und auch viele Arbeitgeber haben eingesehen, dass das ja auch für die Produktivität und alles eine wirklich gute Sache ist, ein gutes Arbeitsklima. Aber bis wir es wirklich schaffen, dass so 70, 80, 90 Prozent der Leute mitmachen, was sehr viel ist bei solchen Befragungen. Häufig ist das leider völlig umgekehrt und es werden ziemlich unzulässige Flüsse gezogen aus sowas.
Man fragt vier Leute und dann...
Unglaublich. Und dafür werden dann eine rasende Menge Geld in den Rechen gesetzt.
Okay, aber jetzt mal zurück zu den Ergebnissen.
Also Bewusstsein ist da. Die Problematik liegt oft eher in der Management-Ebene. So ein Thema ist halt hochpolitisch. Also es ist eher die Angst da. Und ein Manager oder ein Betriebsrat oder beides, wenn sie sowas machen wollen, brauchen also, das erleben wir immer wieder, ein rundes Dreivierteljahr, um politisch intern abzusichern, ob man denn sowas machen kann.
Okay, das ist aber erstmal ein gutes Zeichen, dass man eben erst nachdenkt, abwägt und für und wieder irgendwie gegeneinander stellt. Das halte ich für eine wichtige Sache.
Also es tut sich fast, in jeder Hinsicht. Und ich sage das auch den Leuten, die so ein bisschen frustriert, dann immer zurück und sagen, die haben sich immer noch nicht entschieden, die wissen nicht, das ist doch eigentlich gut. Also auf ziemlich breiter Front ist da ein Bewusstsein da. Allerdings gibt es auch viel, viel Angst. Es gibt nicht nur dieses Positive, was machen die da neugierig, sondern schlichte Angst. Es kommt auch immer wieder vor, dass wir Fragebögen kriegen. Die Mitarbeiter haben also auch die Möglichkeit, uns die direkt zuzuschicken, falls sie irgendwie ihren Betrieb da nicht trauen. Auch wenn die anonymen sind, die sind nicht mal mit handschriftlichen Kreuzen, sondern mit einer Schreibmaschine ausgefüllt. Also fortvollkommene Paranoia.
Kannst du mal ein bisschen näher darauf eingehen, was ihr da so für Fragen stellt? Also worum geht es überhaupt?
Wir stellen Fragen, die darauf abzielen, festzustellen, wie arbeiten Leute eigentlich zusammen? Woher wissen sie, ob sie ihre Arbeit gut oder schlecht machen? Kriegen sie überhaupt Feedback? Vertrauensfragen, eben auch so etwas, Überwachung spielt da eine Rolle. Ist ein standardisierter Fragebogen, sozialwissenschaftliches, anonymes Verfahren. Also nicht unbedingt Rocket Science, aber halt in dieser Breite, nämlich in Deutschland sehr sehr ungewöhnlich. Und der Witz ist, das Ganze basiert auf dem Benchmarking. Also es nützt ja überhaupt nichts, wenn jemand sagt, das ist gut, mittel, gut oder schlecht oder Schulnote 1 bis 6. Sondern ob eine Schulnote 3 gut oder schlecht ist, dazu muss man wissen, was für einen Arbeitsplatz man befragt.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagt, so ein Misstrauen in Bezug auf Datenschutz, kann er eben dazu führen, dass das Betriebsklima insgesamt viel schlechter wird. Ist das so eine Aussage, die ihr daraus gewinnen könnt?
Ja, man kann ganz deutlich sehen, in dem konkreten Fall, das Beste wäre gewesen, wenn es hier Wohlüberwachung gibt. Aber wenn das auch jedem bekannt ist und auch klar kommuniziert ist, wo findet die Stadt, wie findet die Stadt, wer hat darauf Zugriff und so weiter. Also Offenheit ist da ein Thema.
Das sind so die allgemeinen Aussagen, die getroffen werden von den Mitarbeitern. Also dass sie halt schon gerne überwacht werden wollen.
Vorsicht, dafür geben unsere Untersuchungen keinen Beleg. Da muss man aufpassen, die Statistik kann auch nicht alles beantworten. Ich will damit nur sagen, wenn jemand sagt, wir machen sowas gar nicht und es gibt überhaupt keine Information, dann ist das schlechter, als wenn jemand sagt, es gibt Überwachung und zwar da und da.
Kriegt ihr denn auch im Rücklauf, wie eure Ergebnisse weiterverwendet wurden in den Betrieben, also irgendwie, wie die umgesetzt wurden?
Das ist vom Betrieb zu Betrieb sehr verschieden. Das bestimmt natürlich der Betriebsrat, das Management, die dort Beteiligten, auch mal der Datenschutzbeauftragte, sowieso es eingibt. Das ist sehr, sehr verschieden. Und da müssen wir auch respektieren, was die Leute da im Betrieb jeweils wollen. Also höchst unterschiedlich.
Na, vielleicht magst du uns noch mal eine Mail schreiben an chaosradio.ccc.de. Vielleicht können wir da noch mal in Kontakt bleiben. Ich glaube, das würde uns noch ein bisschen genauer interessieren.
Großes Interesse auf allen Seiten.
Alles klar, ja schicke ich mal los.
Ich habe noch eine Frage. Gehen die Daten jetzt wirklich nur an die Betriebe selber wieder? Oder wertet die noch anderweitig aus? Also in Form von Studien, so allgemeinen Studien?
Nee, das machen wir nicht. Das Einzige, worauf das Ganze basiert, wir schreiben mit den Daten unsere Benchmarks vor. Wir gucken also, wir haben einen Arbeitsplatz, wo Leute in der großen, zugigen Werkhalle große, schwere Maschinen zusammenbauen. Ob das dann Baggerlogomotiven oder Panzer sind, spielt keine Rolle. Das sind dann vergleichbare Arbeitsplätze. Mehr machen wir nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ganz wichtig. Also sonst würden, wenn wir da nicht glaubwürdig wären, dann wären die Rücklaufquoten sicherlich schlechter.
Aber man könnte ja gleich sagen, wie das die Ergebnisse anonymen für weitere Studien zur Verfügung gestellt wären. Also ich meine, es wäre schon interessant, auch mal die Ergebnisse unabhängig von dem Betrieb selber, sondern halt wirklich eingegrenzt auf Produktion oder Dienstleistung auch mal die Ergebnisse anderweitig aufgearbeitet zu sehen.
Ja, unsere Wissenschaftler bei uns in der Initiative sagen, da sind wir noch nicht weit genug, da müssen wir noch ein paar Daten sammeln. Dass das in einer einen oder anderen Dissertation irgendwann mal verwurstet wird.
Um ein Fazit zu finden, das bleibt spannend.
Wo du gerade sagst, Daten sammeln, das heißt, ihr bewahrt die Ergebnisse dann doch schon auf, oder?
Nein, es sind also keine personenbezogenen Daten. Und zum anderen wird auch nicht aufbewahrt, wie viele Antworten wir haben. Wir bewahren lediglich die unterschiedlichen Indizes, die Benchmarks auf.
Ja genau, richtig vorbildlich.
Das allerdings ist nicht unbedingt ein Marketingargument, weil die meisten Leute das einfach nicht begreifen, worin die Vorbildlichkeit liegt.
Das heißt, es bleibt noch viel zu tun. Danke dir, Stefan.
Es bleibt noch viel zu tun.
Uns läuft ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg jetzt. Ich verstehe, dass du das total spannend findest, aber wir haben noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen. Außerdem kommt auch gleich Tobi Koch mit dem Night Flight. Wir fassen mal so ein bisschen zusammen, das Chaosradio von heute ist 143 zum Thema Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Ich würde sagen, es gibt auf jeden Fall ein Bewusstsein. Viele Leute machen sich Sorgen und denken auch ernsthaft drüber nach, ist das, was jetzt hier in meinem Umfeld passiert, ist das schon eine Beschnüfflung oder ist es irgendwie noch okay, was der Chef so macht? Also das ist da. Was nicht da ist, ist eine geregelte rechtliche Grundlage, weil sich der und die Gesetzgeber da immer wieder fein mal drum drücken. So was zu tun und so wie es im Moment aussieht, wird es in dieser Legislaturperiode auch nicht mehr passieren.
Ja, da hat der Herr Minister Schäuble den lustigen Satz gesagt, also einen Schnellschuss machen wir jetzt nicht mehr. Wir sollten halt mal überlegen, was wollen wir denn eigentlich drin haben in diesem Gesetz? Also ich denke, es hat sich aus der Sendung und ganz gut herauskristallisiert, was wir fordern wollen. Das eine ist, was jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen wurde, wir müssen bessere Rechte haben für Betriebsräte und für betriebliche Datenschutzbeauftragte. Das ist eine wichtige Sache. Wir brauchen eine ganz klare Regelung für die Videoüberwachung, eine restriktive Regelung, das ist vollkommen klar. Wir brauchen eine übersichtliche Regelung für Internet- und Mailüberwachung. Wir haben gesehen, dass wir die Bereiche sind, wo viele drüber reden. Klar, wir brauchen viel strengere Regeln für die Weitergabe von Personalräten, auch etwa bei Versetzungen oder in Konzernen, sodass die Arbeitnehmer und aber auch die Bewerber, haben wir auch gehört, konkret zustimmen müssen. Das finde ich sehr wichtig. Und wir brauchen ein Verbot von diesen Gentests, auch wenn sie freiwillig sind. Das finde ich auch sehr wichtig. Und wir müssen noch etwas fordern. Ich finde, dass die betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten genauso wie Betriebsräte teilweise in ihrer Arbeitszeit für diese Arbeit freigestellt werden. Denn wir haben gesehen, die machen offenbar noch nicht genug. Und das tun sie deshalb nicht, weil sie nicht genug Zeit freigestellt bekommen. Also ich glaube, das sind so die wesentlichen Forderungen. Die sind teilweise Jahre alt. Jetzt müssen die mal kommen. Aber ich bin wieder zu Kämpfer, soll ich die Klappe halten?
Nein, nein, alles gut, alles gut. Also ihr seht, es bleibt noch eine Menge zu tun. Das Chaosradio für heute schließt die Pforten. Ihr könnt es noch mal nachhören auf chaosradio.ccc.de Ja, Starbuck, alles gut. Lass mich doch erstmal kurz meinen Sermon machen. chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es den Podcast. Da gibt es auch Chaosradio Express mit noch mehr Technik, Geek, Nerd, Wahnsinn, den ihr gerne haben möchtet. Fritz.de klicken, da steht die Playlist zur Sendung. Und ansonsten sei noch auf ccc.de verwiesen, denn da gibt es die anstehenden nächsten Termine, unter anderem die SIG-Imte, die stattfindet in Köln vom 22.24.Mai und den Datengarten Starbuck.
Ich wollte dir den ganzen Wort verlegen, ich wollte nur Konstanz darauf hinweisen, dass sie das noch in die Suche haben.
Ja, weil ich so vergessen bin. Wir haben nämlich wieder einen Datengarten, der 30. ein Jubiläum und der steht unter dem Motto Hack the System und Friedemann kommt und erzählt uns mal ein bisschen von einem Projekt, was OpenLoco heißt. Wir machen uns einfach mal keinen Gedanken um diesen seltsamen Namen. Aber es geht ein bisschen darüber, wie man Interessen durchsetzt gegenüber Politik und Wirtschaft. Also, das ist am 26. Februar, um 8.00 Uhr. Also morgen.
In den Klubräumen, also in den Berliner Klubräumen, das ist Marienstrasse 11, im Hinterhaus. In Mitte.
Also eigentlich ist das heute, fast.
Na ja, in drei Minuten.
Ihr könnt im Prinzip gleich hinfahren und warten.
Allklar.
Genau, das sollten wir noch sagen.
Das war das Chaosradio mit Constanze Starbuck. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Mitmachen. Weiter diskutieren geht natürlich auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Hier geht es weiter mit Tobi Koch und dem Night Flight. Und wenn alles gut geht, haben wir jetzt schon ein Thema für die nächste Sendung. Dann wird es nämlich, wenn alles so geplant ist, wie es läuft, um Datenrettung gehen. Wann habe ich eigentlich den letzten Backup gemacht?
Das frag dich mal. Denken wir auch mal zu den Hörern.
Denk mal drüber nach. Bis zum nächsten Mal.